the following is a conversation with
eugenia cuida
co-founder of replica which is an app
that allows you to make friends
with an artificial intelligence system a
chatbot
that learns to connect with you on an
emotional
you can even say a human level by being
a friend
for those of you who know my interest in
ai and views on life in general
know that replica and eugenia's line of
work
is near and dear to my heart the origin
story of replica is grounded in a
personal tragedy
of eugenia losing her close friend roman
mazarenki
who was killed crossing the street by a
hit-and-run driver
in late 2015. he was 34.
the app started as a way to grieve the
loss of a friend
by training a chatbot neural net on text
messages between eugenia and roman
the rest is a beautiful human story as
we talk about with eugenia
when a friend mentioned eugenia's work
to me i knew i had to meet her and talk
to her
i felt before during and after that
this meeting would be an important one
in my life and it was
i think in ways that only time will
truly show to me
and others she's a kind and brilliant
person
it was an honor and a pleasure to talk
to her
quick summary of the sponsors doordash
dollar shave club
and cash app click the sponsor links in
the description to get a discount and
to support this podcast as a side note
let me say that deep meaningful
connection between
human beings and artificial intelligence
systems
is a lifelong passion for me i'm not yet
sure where that passion will take me but
i decided some time ago that i will
follow it boldly
and without fear to as far as i can take
it
with a bit of hard work and a bit of
luck i hope i'll succeed in helping
build ai systems
that have some positive impact on the
world and on the lives of a few people
out there
but also it is entirely possible
that i am in fact one of the chatbots
that eugenia
and the replica team have built and this
podcast
is simply a training process for the
neural net that's trying to learn to
connect
to human beings one episode at a time
in any case i wouldn't know if i was or
wasn't
and if i did i wouldn't tell you if you
enjoyed this thing subscribe on youtube
review it with five stars on apple
podcast
follow on spotify support on patreon or
connect with me on twitter
at lex friedman as usual i'll do a few
minutes of ads now and no ads in the
middle
i'll try to make these interesting but
give you timestamps so you can skip
but please do still check out the
sponsors by clicking the links in the
description
to get a discount buy whatever they're
selling it really is the best way to
support this podcast
this show is sponsored by dollar shave
club try them out with a one-time
offer for only five bucks and free
shipping at dollarshave.com
lex the starter kit comes with a six
blade razor
refills and all kinds of other stuff
that makes shaving feel
great i've been a member of dollar shave
club for
over five years and actually signed up
when i first heard about them
on the joe rogan experience podcast and
now
friends we have come full circle it
feels like i made it
now that i can do a read for them just
like joe did all those years ago
back when he also did ads for some less
reputable companies let's say you know
about
if you're a true fan of the old school
podcasting world
anyway i just used the razer and the
refills but they told me i should really
try out the shave butter
i did i love it it's translucent somehow
which is a cool new experience again
try the ultimate shave starter set today
for just five bucks plus free shipping
at dollarshaveclub.com
lex this show is also sponsored by
doordash get five dollars off as your
delivery fee is in your first order of
15 bucks or more
when you download the doordash app and
enter code
you guessed it i have so many memories
of working late nights for a deadline
with a team of engineers
whether that's for my phd at google or
mit
and eventually taking a break to argue
about which door dash restaurant to
order from
and when the food came those moments of
bonding of exchanging ideas of pausing
to shift attention from the programs the
humans
were special for a bit of time i'm on my
own now so i missed that camaraderie but
actually i still use doordash a lot
there's a million options that fit into
my crazy keto diet ways
also it's a great way to support
restaurants in these challenging times
once again download the doordash app and
enter code lex to get five bucks off
it's your delivery fees and your first
order of fifteen dollars or more
finally this shows presented by cash app
the number one finance app in the app
store
i can truly say that they're an amazing
company
one of the first sponsors if not the
first sponsor to
truly believe in me and and i think
quite possibly the reason i'm still
doing this podcast so
i'm forever grateful to cash app so
thank you and as i said many times
before
use code lex podcast when you download
the app from google play or the app
store
cash app lets you send money to friends
buy bitcoin invest in the stock market
with as little as one dollar i usually
say other stuff here in the read but i
wasted all that time
up front saying how grateful i am to
cash out i'm going to try
to go off the top of my head a little
bit more for these reads
because i'm actually very lucky to be
able to choose the sponsors that we take
on
and that means i can really only take on
the sponsors that i truly love
and then i can just talk about why i
love them so it's pretty simple
again get cash app from the app store
google play use code lex podcast
get 10 bucks and cash app will also
donate 10 bucks to first
an organization that is helping to
advance robotics and stem education
for young people around the world and
now
here's my conversation with eugenia
cuida
okay before we talk about ai and the
amazing work you're doing
let me ask you ridiculously we're both
russian so let me ask you a ridiculously
romanticized russian question
do you think human beings are
alone like fundamentally on a
philosophical level
like in our existence when we
like go through life do you think
um just the nature of our
life is loneliness
yeah so we have to read dostoevsky at
school
as you probably know yeah
i mean it's part of the your school
program um
so i guess if you read that then you
sort of have to believe that
you're made to believe that you're
fundamentally alone
and that's how you live your life how do
you think about it
you have a lot of friends but at the end
of the day
do you have like a longing for
connection with other people
that's maybe another way of asking it do
you think that's ever fully satisfied
i think we are fundamentally alone we're
born alone we die alone but
um you know but i view my whole life as
trying to
get away from that trying to not feel
uh feel lonely and again we're talking
about you know subjective
kind of way of feeling alone it doesn't
necessarily mean that you don't have any
connections or
you're actually isolated you think it's
a subjective
thing but like again another absurd
measurement-wise thing how much
loneliness do you think there is in the
world
so like if you see loneliness as a
as a condition how much of it
is there do you think like how
i guess how many you know there's all
kinds of studies and measures of
how much you know how many people in the
world feel alone there's all these
like measures of how many people are you
know self-report
or just all these kinds of different
measures but in your own perspective
um how big of a problem do you think it
is
size-wise well i'm actually fascinated
by the topic of loneliness
i try to read about it as much as i can
um what really and there i think there's
a paradox because
loneliness is not a clinical disorder
it's not something that you can get your
insurance to pay for if you're
struggling with that
yet it's it's actually proven and pretty
you know tons of papers tons of research
around that it has proven
um that it's correlated with earlier
um life expectancy shorter life span
and it is you know in a way like right
now what scientists would say that it
you know it's a little bit worse than
being obese so not actually doing any
physical activity
in your life the impact on your
interests have impact on your
physiological health yeah so
it's basically puts you if you're
constantly feeling lonely
um your body responds like it's
basically all the time under stress
so it's always in this alert um alerts
say
and so it's really bad for you because
it actually like drops your immune
system and get
it your response to inflammation is
quite different so
all the cardiovascular vascular diseases
actually responds to
viruses so it's much easier to catch a
virus that's sad now that
we're living in a pandemic and it's
probably making us a lot more alone
and it's probably weakening the immune
system making us more susceptible to the
virus
it's kind of sad
yeah the statistics are the sticks are
pretty pretty horrible around that so
around thirty percent
of all millennials report that they're
feeling lonely constantly
thirty thirty percent and then it's much
worse for jan z
and then twenty percent of millennials
say that they feel lonely and they also
don't have any
close friends and then um i think 25 or
so and then 20 percent would say they
don't even have acquaintances
this is the united states that's in the
united states and i'm pretty sure that
that's much worse everywhere else like
in the uk i mean it was white
widely like tweeted and uh posted when
they were talking about a minister of
loneliness that they wanted to appoint
because four out of ten
you people in uk feel lonely so i think
we don't understand
i mean that i think that thing actually
exists um
so yeah you you you will die sooner
if you if you are lonely and again that
this is only when we're only talking
about
your perception of loneliness of feeling
lonely that is not objectively
fully so being fully socially isolated
however the combination of being fully
socially isolated
and not having many connections and also
feeling lonely that's pretty much a
deadly
combination so it strikes me bizarre
or strange that this is a wide known
fact and then there's really no one
working really on that because it's a
subclinical it's not clinical it's not
something that you can
we'll tell your doctor and get a
treatment or something yet it's
killing us yeah so there's a bunch of
people
trying to evaluate like try to measure
the problem by looking at like
how social media is affecting loneliness
and all that kind of stuff so it's like
measurement
like if you look at the field of
psychology they're trying to measure the
problem
and not that many people actually but
some
but you're basically saying how many
people are trying to solve
the problem like how would you
try to solve the problem of
loneliness like if you just stick to
humans
uh i mean or basically not just the
humans but the technology that connects
us humans
do you think there's a hope for that
technology to do the connection
like are you on social media much
unfortunately
do you find yourself like again if you
sort of introspect about
how connected you feel to other human
beings how not alone you feel do you
think social media makes it better or
worse
maybe for you personally or in in
general
i think it's it's easier to look at some
stats and
um i mean gen z's seem to be generation
z seems to be
much lonelier than millennials in terms
of however they report loneliness
they're definitely the most connected
you know generation in the world i mean
i still remember life without without an
iphone
without facebook they don't know that
that ever existed
uh or at least don't know how it was um
so that tells me a little bit about the
fact that that might be um
you know this hyperconnected world is
might actually make people feel
lonely lonelier i don't know exactly
what the
what the measurements are around that
but i would say in my personal
experience i think it does make you feel
a lot lonelier
mostly yeah we're all super connected
but i think loneliness the feeling of
loneliness doesn't come from
not having any social connections
whatsoever again tons of people that are
in long-term relationships experienced
bouts of loneliness and continued
loneliness
and it's more the question about the
true connection about actually
being deeply seen deeply understood
and in a way it's also about your
relationship with yourself like in order
to not feel lonely
you actually need to have a better
relationship and
feel more connected to yourself then
this feeling actually starts to go away
a little bit
and then you um open up
yourself to actually meeting other
people in a very special way
uh not just you know add a friend on
facebook kind of way
so just to briefly touch on it i mean do
you think
it's possible to form that kind of
connection with
ai systems more downline of some of your
work
do you think that's um engineering-wise
a possibility to alleviate loneliness
is not with another human but with an ai
system
well i know that's that's a fact that's
what we're doing
and we see it and we measure that and we
see how people start to feel less lonely
talking to their virtual ai friend
so basically a chatbot at the basic
level but could be more
like do you have i'm not even speaking
sort of uh
about specifics but do you have a hope
like if you look
50 years from now do you have a hope
that there's just like
ais that are like optimized
for um let me let me first start like
right now the way people perceive ai
which is recommender systems for
facebook and twitter social media
they see ais basically destroying first
of all the fabric of our civilization
but second of all
making us more lonely do you see like a
world where it's possible just have
ai systems floating about that like
make our life less lonely
yeah make us happy make like our
putting good things into the world in
terms of our individual lives
yeah totally believe it and that that's
why we're i'm also working on that
um i think we need to also make sure
that
um what we're trying to optimize for
we're actually measuring
and it is a north star metric that we're
going after and all of our product and
our all of our business models are
optimized for that
because you can talk you know a lot of
products that talk about
um you know making you feel less lonely
or making you feel more connected
they're not really measuring that so
they don't really know whether their
users are actually
feeling less lonely in the long run or
feeling more connected in the long run
um so i think it's really important to
put your measure yep to measure it
what's uh what's a good measurement of
loneliness
well so that's something that i'm really
interested in
how do you measure that people are
feeling better or that they're feeling
less lonely
with lowliness there's a scale there's a
ucla 20 and ucla 3 recently scale which
is basically a questionnaire that you
fill out
and you can see whether in the long run
it's improving or not
and that uh does it capture the
momentary
feeling of loneliness does it look in
like
the past month like uh is it basically a
self-report does it try to sneak up on
you
it's very tricky to answer honestly or
something like that
well what's yeah i'm not familiar with
the question it is just asking you a few
questions like how often did you feel
like lonely or how often did you feel
connected to other people in this last
few
couple weeks um it's similar to
the self-report questionnaires for
depression and anxiety like phq9 and
get seven of course any as any
self-report
questionnaires that's not necessarily
very precise so very
well measured but still if you take a
big enough population you
get them through these uh questionnaires
you can see
you can see the positive dynamic and so
you basically uh
you put people through questionnaires to
see like is this thing
is our is what we're creating making
people happier
yeah we measure so we measure two
outcomes one short term right after the
conversation we asked people whether
this conversation made them feel better
worse or same
um this this metric right now is at
eighty percent
so eighty percent of all our
conversations make people feel better
but i should have done the questionnaire
with you
you feel a lot worse after we've done
this conversation
that's actually fascinating i should
probably do that
but that's that's sorry you should
totally and aim for 80
aim to outperform your current
state-of-the-art ai system
uh in these human conversations so again
we'll get to
your work with replica but let me
continue on the line of absurd questions
so you it talks about um you know deep
connection with the humans deep
connection with the
ai meaningful connection let me ask
about love people make fun of me because
i talk about love all the time
but uh what what do you think a love is
like maybe in the context of um a
meaningful connection with somebody else
do you draw a distinction between love
like friendship and facebook friends
or is it a graduate no is it
it's all the same no like is it just a
gradual thing or is there
something fundamental about us humans
that seek
like a really deep connection uh
with another human being and what is
that
what is love eugenia
um well the way i see it um specifically
um the way it relates to our work and
the way it was
the way it inspired our work on replica
um i think one of the biggest and the
most precious gifts we can give to each
other
now in 2020 as humans is this
gift of deep empathetic understanding
the feeling of being deeply seen like
what does that mean like that
you exist like somebody acknowledging
the somebody
seeing you for who you actually are and
that's extremely extremely rare
i think that is that combined with
unconditional positive regard
belief and trust that
you internally are always inclined for
positive growth and
believing you in this way letting you be
a separate person at the same time and
this deep
empathetic understanding for me that's
the that's the
combination that really creates
something special something that people
when they feel it once they will always
long for it again
and something that starts huge
fundamental changes in people
um when we see that someone's accepts us
so deeply we start to accept ourselves
and
the paradoxes that's when big changes
start start happening big fundamental
changes and people start happening
so i think that is the ultimate
therapeutic relationship that is
and that might be in some way definition
of love
so so acknowledging that there's a
separate person and accepting
you for who you are now
on a slightly so that and you mentioned
therapeutic that sounds very like a very
healthy view of love
but uh is there also like uh
like you know if we look at heartbreak
and uh you know most love songs are
probably about heartbreak right
is that like the mystery the tension the
danger
the fear of loss you know
all of that what people might see in a
negative light as like games
or whatever but just
just the the dance of human interaction
yeah fear of loss and fear of like
you said like once you feel it once you
long for it again
but you also once you feel it once you
might for many people
they've lost it so they fear losing it
they feel lost
so is that part of it like you're you're
speaking like beautifully about like the
positive things but
is it important to be able to uh be
afraid of losing it
from an engineering perspective
i mean it's a huge part of it and
unfortunately we all
you know face it at some points in our
lives i mean
i did you want to go into details how
did you get your heart broken
sure well so mine is pretty straight my
source pretty straightforward
um there
i did have a friend that was you know
that at some point um
in my 20s became really really close to
me and we we became really close friends
um i grew up pretty lonely so in many
ways when i'm building
you know this these ai friends i think
about myself when i was 17 writing
horrible poetry and you know in my
dial-up modem at home and
um you know and that was the feeling
that i grew up with i left
i lived um alone for a long time when i
was a teenager
where did you grow up in moscow and then
outskirts of moscow
um so i just skateboard during the day
and come back home and you know
connect to the internet and write
pokemon and then write horrible poetry
and was it love poems
all sorts of points obviously love poems
i mean what what other poetry can you
write when you're 17.
it could be political or something but
yeah but that was you know that was kind
of my
yeah like deeply um influenced by joseph
brodsky and like all sorts of spots that
um every 17 year old will
will be looking you know looking at and
reading
but yeah that was my uh these were my
teenage years and
i just never had a person that i thought
would you know take me
as it is would accept me the way i am um
and i just thought you know working and
just doing my thing and being angry at
the world and
being a reporter i was an investigative
reporter working undercover and
writing about people was my way to
connect with
you know with with others i i was deeply
curious about every
everyone else and i thought that you
know if i go out there if i write their
stories
that means i'm more connected this is
what this podcast is about by the way
i'm desperate alone seeking connection
i'm just kidding or am i i don't know so
what wait
a reporter uh what
how did that make you feel more
connected i mean you're
still fundamentally pretty alone but
you're always with other people you know
you're always thinking about what other
place gonna infiltrate what other
community can i write about what other
phenomena can i explore and he's sort of
like a trickster you know and like
and a mythological character like
creature that's just jumping
uh between all sorts of different worlds
and feel and feel sort of okay with
in all of them so um that was my dream
job by the way that was like
totally what i would have been doing um
if russia was a different place and a
little bit undercover so like you
weren't
you were trying to like you said
mythological creature trying to
infiltrate
so try to be a part of the world what
are we talking about what kind of things
did you enjoy writing about i'd go work
at a strip club
or go
awesome okay uh well i'd go work at a
restaurant
or just go write about you know um
certain phenomenons or phenomenons of
people in in the city
and what uh sorry to keep interrupting
i'm the worst
a conversationalist what
stage of russia is this what uh is this
pre-putin
post-putin what was russia like
pre-putin is really long ago
uh this is putin era that's uh beginning
of 2000's
and 2010 2007 8 9 10.
what were strip clubs like in russia and
restaurants and
culture and people's minds like in that
early russia that you were covering
in those early 2000s was there was still
a lot of hope there was still tons of
hope that
um you know we're
sort of becoming this uh western
westernized society the restaurants were
opening we were really looking
and you know um we're trying we're
trying to copy a lot of things from
uh from the us from europe uh bringing
all these things and very enthusiastic
about that
so there's a lot of you know stuff going
on there's a lot of hope and
dream for this you know new moscow that
would be
similar to i guess new york i mean just
to give you an idea and
um year 2000 was the year one
we had two uh movie theaters in moscow
and there was this one first coffee
house that opened
and it was like really big deal by 2010
there were
all sorts of things everywhere almost
like a chain like a starbucks type of
coffee house or like you mean oh yeah
like a starbucks i mean i remember we
were
reporting on like we were writing about
the opening of starbucks i think in 2007
that was one of the biggest things that
happened and
you know in moscow back back in the time
like that was worthy of a magazine cover
and uh that was definitely the you know
the biggest talk of the time
yeah when was mcdonald's because i was
still in russia when mcdonald's opened
that was in the 90s i mean yeah i
remember that very well
yeah those were long long lines i think
it was 1990
three or four i don't remember um
mcdonald's at that time did you do that
i mean that was a luxurious
outing that was definitely not something
you do every day and also the line was
at least three hours
so if you're going to mcdonald's that is
not fast food that is like at least
three hours in line
yeah and then no one is trying to eat
fast after that everyone is like trying
to enjoy as much as possible
what's your memory of that oh it was
insane extremely positive
it's a small strawberry milkshake and a
hamburger and small fries and my mom's
there and
sometimes i'll just because i was really
little they'll just let me run
you know up the cashier and like cut the
line
which is like you cannot really do that
in russia or
so like for a lot of people like a lot
of those experiences might seem
not very fulfilling you know like it's
on the verge of poverty i suppose but
do you remember all that time fondly
like
because i do like the first time i drink
you know coke
you know all that stuff right um
and just yeah the connection with other
human beings in russia
i remember i remember really positively
like how do you remember what the 90s
and then the rush you were covering
just the human connections you had with
people
and the experiences well my
my parents were both both physicists my
grandparents were both
well my grandpa grandfather was an
um nuclear physicist a professor at the
university
my dad worked at chernobyl when i was
born in chernobyl
analyzing kind of the everything after
the explosion
and then i remember that and they were
so they were making
sort of enough money in the soviet union
so they were not you know
extremely poor or anything it was pretty
prestigious to be a professor
uh the dean and the university and i
remember my grandfather started making a
hundred dollars a month
after you know in the 90s so then i
remember we started
our main line of work would be to go to
our
little tiny country house get a lot of
apples there from apple trees bring them
back to
to to the city and sell them in the
street
so me and my nuclear physicist
grandfather were just standing there and
he
selling those apples the whole day
because that would make you more money
than
you know working at the university and
then he'll just tell me try to teach me
um you know something about planets and
whatever
the particles and stuff and you know i'm
not
smart at all so i could never understand
anything but i was interested as a you
know journalist
kind of type interested but that was my
memory and you know i'm happy that i
wasn't
um i somehow got spared that i was
probably too young to remember any of
the traumatic stuff so
the only thing i really remember had
this bootleg that was very traumatic
i had this bootleg nintendo which was
called dandy in russia
so in 1993 there was nothing to eat like
even if you had any money you would go
to the store and there was no food i
don't know if you remember that
and our friend had a um restaurant like
a
government half government owned
something restaurant
so they always had um supplies so he
exchanged a big bag of weed
for this nintendo that looked like
nintendo
and then i remember very fondly because
i think it was nine
or something like that and or seven
traumatic because we just got it and i
was playing it and there was this you
know dandy tv show
yeah um so dramatically positive sense
you mean like
like a definitive well they took it away
and gave me a
bag of wheat instead and i cried like my
eyes out for
days days and days oh no and then you
know as a
and my dad said we're gonna like
exchange it back in a little bit so you
keep the little
gun you know the one that you shoot the
ducks with so i'm like okay i'm keeping
the gun so sometimes it's going to come
back
but then they exchanged the gun as well
for some sugar or something
i was so pissed i was like i didn't want
to eat for days after that i'm like i
don't want your food
my nintendo that was extremely traumatic
um but you know i was happy that that
was my only
traumatic experience you know my dad had
to actually go to chernobyl with a bunch
of
20 year olds he was 20 when he went to
uh chernobyl
and that was right after the explosion
no one knew anything the whole crew he
went with
all of them are dead now i think there
was this one guy uh still
that was still alive for this last few
years i think he died a few years ago
now
my dad somehow luckily got back earlier
than everyone else
but just the fact that that was the and
i was always like well how did they send
you i was only i was just born
you know you had a newborn talk about
paternity leave they're like
but that's who they took because they
didn't know whether you would be able to
have kids when you come back
so they took the ones with kids so him
with
some guys want to and i'm just thinking
of me
when i was 20 i was so sheltered from
any problems whatsoever in life and then
my dad
um his 21st birthday
at the reactor you like work three hours
a day you sleep the rest
and and i yeah so i played with a lot of
toys from chernobyl
what are your memories of chernobyl in
in general like
a bigger context you know because of
that hbo show
the world's attention turned to it once
again like what are your thoughts about
chernobyl
did russia screw that one up like
you know there's probably a lot of
lessons about our modern times with
data about coronavirus and all that kind
of stuff it seems like
there's a lot of misinformation there's
a lot of
people kind of trying to hide whether
they've screwed something up or not
as it's very understandable it's very
human very wrong probably
but obviously russia was probably trying
to hide
that they've screwed things up
like what are your thoughts about that
time personal and
in general i mean i was born when the
explosion happened
so actually a few months after so of
course i don't remember anything
apart from the fact that my dad would
bring me tiny
toys plus like plastic things that would
just go crazy haywire when you
you know put the gagger
my mom was like just nuclear about that
um i was like what are you bringing you
should not do that
uh she was nuclear very nice absolutely
well done
well uh but yeah but the tv show was
just
phenomenal i mean yeah it's definitely
first of all it's an incredible how um
that was made not by the russians
but someone else but capturing so well
everything about the you know about our
country
um it felt a lot more genuine that most
of the movies and tv shows are made now
in russia just so much more genuine
and most of my friends in russia were
just in complete awe about the
with the show but i think that how good
of a job they did oh my god phenomenal
but all the apartments there's something
yeah the set design i mean russians
can't do that
we you know but you you see everything
and it's like wow that's exactly how it
was
it's so i i don't know that show
i don't know what to think about that
because it's british accents
british actors of a person
i forgot who created the show i'm not
but i remember reading about him and
he's not he doesn't even feel like like
there's no russia in his history
no he did like super bad or some like or
like uh
i don't know yeah like exactly whatever
that thing about the bachelor party in
vegas uh
number four and five or something were
the ones that he worked yeah
but so he made me feel really sad for
some reason that
if a person obviously a genius could go
in and just study
and just be extreme attention to detail
that can do a good job it made me think
like
why don't other people do a good job
with this
like about russia like there's so little
about russia
there's so few good films about
the russian side of world war ii of
i mean there's so much interesting evil
and not and beautiful moments in the
history of the 20th century in russia
it feels like there's not many good
films on
from the russians you would expect
something from the russians
well they keep making these propaganda
movies now oh no
unfortunately but you know chernobyl was
such a perfect tv show i think capturing
really well
it's not about like even the set design
which was phenomenal but
um just capturing all the problems that
exist now with the country and like
um focusing on the right things like if
you build the whole country on a lie
that's what's gonna happen and that's
just this very
simple kind of thing
yeah and did you have your dad talked
about it to you
like his thoughts i think experience
he never talks he's this kind of russian
man that just my husband who's american
and he
asked him a few times like you know igor
how did you
but why did you say yes or like why did
you decide to go you could have said no
not go to chernobyl why would like a
person
like that's what you do you cannot say
no
yeah yeah it's just
it's like a russian way it's the
russians don't talk that much
no there are downsides and upsets for
that
uh yeah that's the truth okay so
back to post-putin russia
or maybe we skipped a few steps along
the way but you were
trying to uh do um to be a journalist
in that time what was what was russia
like at that time
post he said 2007 starbucks type of
thing what else what else was russia
like then
i think there was just hope there was
this big hope that we're going to be
you know friends with the united states
and we're going to be friends with
europe and we're just going to be also a
country like those with
you know um bike lanes and parks and
everything's going to be urbanized again
we're talking about 90s where like
people would be shot in the street
and it was i sort of have a fond memory
of going into a movie theater and
i you know coming out of it after the
movie and the guy that i saw on the
stairs was like playing their shot
which was again it was like a thing in
the 90s that would be happening people
were
you know people were getting shot here
and there
tons of violence tons of uh you know
just basically mafia mobs on
in the streets and then the 2000s were
like you know things just got
cleaned up uh oil went up uh and the
country started getting
a little bit richer you know the 90s
were so
grim mostly because the economy was in
shambles and oil prices were not high so
the country didn't have anything
we defaulted in 1998 and um the money
kept jumping back and forth like first
there were millions of rebels then it
got like default you know then it got to
like thousands there was
one rubble with something then again to
millions
it was like crazy town that was crazy um
and then the 2000s were just
these years of stability in a way and
um the country getting a little bit
richer because of
you know again oil and gas and we were
starting to we started to look at
specifically in moscow and in facebook
to look in at other
cities in europe and new york and us and
trying to do the same in our like small
kind of cities towns there
what was uh what were your thoughts of
putin at the time
well in the beginning he was really
positive everyone was very
you know positive about putin he was
young um
he's very energetic he also intermediate
the sheriff was somewhat compared to
well that was
not like way before the shirtless era um
the shirtless era okay so it didn't
start off shortly when did the shirtless
era that's like the propaganda
of riding horse fishing 2010 11 12.
yeah that's my favorite you know like
people talk about the favorite
beatles like the i don't know that's my
favorite putin that's the shirtless
putin now i remember very very clearly
1996 where
you know americans really helped russia
with elections and yeltsin got reelected
thankfully so because there's a huge
threat that actually the communists will
get back to power
they were a lot more popular and then a
lot of american
experts political experts and campaign
experts
descended on moscow and helped yeltsin
actually get
yeah the presidency the second term for
the pro um of the presidency but
elsinore was not feeling great you know
in the
by the end of his second term uh he was
you know
alcoholic he was really old he was
falling off
uh you know the stages when he was
talking
uh so people were looking for it fresh i
think for a fresh face for someone who's
gonna continue yeltsin's
uh work but who's going to be a lot more
energetic and a lot more
active young um efficient maybe
so that's what we all saw in putin back
in the day i i'd say that everyone
absolutely everyone in russia in early
2000s who was not a communist would be
yeah putin's great we have a lot of
hopes for him what are your
thoughts and i promise we'll get back
to uh first of all your love story
second of all ai well what are your
thoughts about
communism the 20th century
i apologize i'm reading the rise and
fall of the third reich
oh my god so i'm like
really steeped into like world war ii
and stalin and hitler and just
these dramatic personalities that
brought so much evil to the world
but it's also interesting to politically
think about
these different systems and what they've
led to
and russia is one of the sort of
beacons of communism in the 20th
century what are your thoughts about
communism having experienced it
as a political system i mean i have only
experienced it a little bit but mostly
through stories and through you know
seeing
my parents my grandparents who lived
through that it was horrible
it was just plain horrible it was just
awful
um you think it's there's something i
mean it sounds
nice on paper
there's uh so like the drawbacks of
capitalism
is that uh you know eventually there
is it's a it's the point of like a
slippery slope
eventually it creates uh
you know the rich get richer it creates
a disparity like inequality
of um wealth inequality
if like you know i guess it's
hypothetical at this point but
eventually capitalism leads to humongous
inequality and that that's you know some
people argue that that's
a source of unhappiness is it's not like
absolute wealth of people it's
the fact that there's a lot of people
much richer than you
there's a feeling of like that's where
unhappiness can come from so the idea of
of communism or this sort of marxism is
uh is is not
allowing that kind of slippery slope but
then you see the actual implementations
of it and still seems to be
seems to go wrong very badly
what do you think that is why does it go
wrong
what is it about human nature if we look
at chernobyl
you know those kinds of barack
bureaucracies that were constructed
is there something like do you think
about this much
of like why it goes wrong well there's
no one was really like
it's not that everyone was equal
obviously the you know the
the government and everyone close to
that were
the bosses so it's not like fully i
guess
uh there's already this dream of equal
life so
then i guess the the situation that we
hadn't
you know the russia and soviet in the
soviet union it was more
it's a bunch of really poor people
without any way to
make any you know significant fortune or
build anything
living constant under constant
surveillance
surveillance from other people like you
can't even you know
do anything that's not fully approved by
the
dictatorship basically otherwise your
neighbor will write
a letter and you'll go to jail absolute
absence of
actual law yeah this constant state of
fear
you didn't own any own anything you
didn't you know the
you couldn't go travel you couldn't read
anything
western or you could make a career
really unless you're working in the
military complex which is why most of
the scientists were
so well regarded i come from you know
both my dad and my mom come from
families of scientists and they they
were really well regarded as you
as you know obviously because this they
wanted i mean
because there's a lot of value to them
being well regarded
because they were developing things that
could be used in in the military
so that was very important that was the
main investment um
but was miserable it was so miserable
that's why you know a lot of russians
now live in the state of constant ptsd
that's why we you know
want to buy buy buy buy and definitely
if as soon as we have the opportunity
you know we just got to it finally that
we can you know own things you know i
remember the time that
we got our first yogurts and that was
the biggest deal in the world
it was already in the 90s by the way i
mean what was your like
favorite food what was like whoa
like this is possible oh fruit because
we only had
apples bananas and whatever and
you know whatever watermelons whatever
you know people would
grow in the soviet union so there were
no pineapples or papaya or mango like
you've never seen those fruit things
like those were so
ridiculously good and obviously you
could not get any like strawberries in
winter
or anything that's not you know seasonal
um
so that was a really big deal seeing all
these fruit things yeah me too actually
i don't know i think i have a
like i don't think i have any too many
demons uh
or like addictions or so on but i think
i've developed an
unhealthy relationship with fruit and i
still struggle with
oh you can get any type of fruit right
you can get like also these weird fruit
fruits like dragon fruit or something
more all kinds of
like different types of peaches like
cherries were killer for me
i know i know you say like we had
bananas and so on but
i don't remember having the kind of
banana like when i first came to this
country the amount of banana
i like literally got fat on bananas
like the amount oh yeah for sure
delicious and like cherries the kind
like just the quality of the food
i was like this is capitalism this is
that's pretty
good it's delicious yeah yeah
yeah it's funny it's funny
yeah like it's it's funny to read
i don't know what to think of it of um
it's funny to think how an idea
that's just written on paper when
carried out
amongst millions of people how that gets
actually
when it becomes reality what it actually
looks like
uh sorry but the
been studying hitler a lot recently and
uh
going through mineconf he uh pretty much
rode out of minecon for everything he
was gonna do
unfortunately most leaders including
stalin didn't read the read it
but it's it's kind of terrifying and i
don't know
and amazing in some sense that you can
have some words on paper
and they can be brought to life and they
can either inspire the world or they can
destroy the world
and uh yeah there's a lot of lessons
to study in history i think people don't
study enough now
i know one of the things i'm hoping with
i've been practicing russian a little
bit
i'm hoping to sort of find
rediscover the the beauty and the terror
of russian history through this
stupid podcast by talking to a few
people
so anyway i just feel like so much was
forgotten i
so much was forgotten i'll probably i'm
gonna try to
convince myself to um you're a super
busy and super important person well
i'm gonna i want to try to befriend you
to uh
to try to become a better russian
because i feel like i'm a shitty russian
not that busy so i can totally be a
russian sherpa
yeah but love
you were you're talking about your early
days of uh
being a little bit alone and finding a
connection with the world through
being a journalist where does love come
into that
i guess finding for the first time um
some friends
it's very you know simple story some
friends that all of a sudden
we i guess we're the same you know the
same
at the same place with our lives um
we're 25 26 i guess
and um somehow remember
and we just got really close and somehow
remember this one day
where um it's one day and you know in
summer that we just stayed out
um outdoor the whole night and just
talked and
for some unknown reason i just felt for
the first time that someone
could you know see me for who i am and
it just felt extremely like extremely
good
and you know we fell asleep outside and
just talking and it was raining it was
beautiful
you know sunrise and it's really cheesy
but
um at the same time we just became
friends in a way that i've never been
friends with anyone else before
and i do remember that before and after
that you sort of have this unconditional
family sort of and it gives you tons of
power
it just basically gives you this
tremendous power to
do things in your life and to um
change positively you mean like on many
different levels
power because you could be yourself at
least you know that some
somewhere you can't be just yourself
like you don't need to pretend you don't
need to be
you know great at work or tell some
story or
sell yourself in some way or another and
so we became this really close friends
and um in a way
um i started a company because he had a
startup and i felt like i kind of want
to start up too
it felt really cool i didn't know what
i'm gonna
what i would uh really do but i felt
like i kind of need a startup
okay so that's so that pulled you in
to the startup world yeah
and then yeah and then this uh
closest friend of mine died we actually
moved here to san francisco together and
then
we went back for a visa to moscow and uh
we lived together with roommates and
we came back and um he got hit by a car
right in front of kremlin
hannah you know next to the river um
and died the same damage
so and you've moved to america
at that point at that point i was like
what about him what about roman
him too he actually moved first so i was
always sort of trying to do what he was
doing so
i didn't like that he was already here
and i was still you know in moscow and
we weren't
hanging out together all the time so was
he in san francisco
yeah we were roommates so he just
visited moscow
for we went back for for our visas we
had to get a stamp and our passport
for our work visas and the embassy was
taking a little longer so we stayed
there for a couple weeks
what happened how did you so how did he
uh how did he die um he was crossing the
street
and the car was going really fast and
way over the speed limit and just
didn't stop on the on the pedestrian
cross on the zebra and
i just ran over him when was this
it was in 2015 on 28th of november so it
was
pretty long ago now um but at the time
you know i was 29 so for me it was
um the first kind of meaningful
death in my life um you know both sets
of
i had both sets of grandparents at the
time i didn't see anyone so close die
and
death sort of existed but as a concept
but definitely not as something that
would be you know
happening to us anytime soon and
specifically our friends because we were
you know we're still in our 20s or early
30s and it still
still felt like the whole life is you
know
you could still dream about ridiculous
things different
um so that was it was just really
really abrupt i'd say what did it
feel like to uh to lose him like that
feeling of loss he talked about
the feeling of love having power what is
the feeling of loss
if you like well in buddhism there's
this concept of samaya
where something really
like huge happens and then you can see
very clearly
um i think that was it like basically
something changed so
changed me so much in such a short
period of time that i could just see
really
really clearly what mattered or what not
well i definitely
saw that whatever i was doing at work
didn't matter at all
and some other things and um it was just
this big realization what
this very very clear vision of what
life's about
you still miss him today
yeah for sure for sure
it was just this constant i think it was
he was really important for for me and
for our friends
for many different reasons and um i
think one of them
being that we didn't just say goodbye to
him but we sort of said
goodbye to our youth in a way it was
like the end of an
era and it's on so many different levels
the end of
moscow as we knew it the end of
you know us living through our 20s and
kind of dreaming about the future
do you remember like last several
conversations
is there moments with him that stick out
that will kind of haunt you
and you're just when you think about him
yeah well his last year here in san
francisco was pretty depressed for
as his startup was not going really
anywhere and he wanted to do something
else he wanted to do
build he played with toy with like
played with the wrong
a bunch of ideas but the last one he had
was around
um building a startup around death
so having um he applied to y combinator
with a video that you know i had on my
computer
and it was all about you know disrupting
death thinking about
new symmetries uh more biologically
like things that could be better
biologically for
for humans and at this end
um at the same time having those um
digital avatars these kind of
ai avatars that would store all the
memory about a person that he could
interact with what year was this
2015. well right before that his death
so it was like a couple months before
that he recorded that video
and so i found out my computer when um
it was in our living room
he never got in but um he was thinking
about a lot
somehow does it have the digital avatar
idea
yeah that's so interesting well he just
says well
that's in his yeah the fish has this
idea and he'll he talks about like i
want to rethink how people grieve and
how people
talk about death why was he interested
in this and i
is it maybe someone who's depressed
yeah is like naturally inclined thinking
about that
but i just felt you know this year in
san francisco we just had so much um
i was going through a hard time he was
going through a hard time and we were
definitely
i was trying to make him just happy
somehow to make him feel better
and it felt like you know this um i
don't know i just
felt like i was taking care of off him a
lot
and he almost started feel better and
then
that happened and
i don't know i just felt i just felt
lonely again i guess and that was
you know coming back to san francisco in
december our
help you know helped organize the
funeral help help his parents
and i came back here and it was a really
lonely apartment a bunch of his clothes
everywhere
and christmas time and
i remember had a board meeting with my
investors and i just couldn't talk about
like
i had to pretend everything's okay and
you know just working on this company
um yeah it was definitely very
very tough tough time do you think about
your
own mortality you said uh
you know we're young the the
the the possibility of doing all kinds
of crazy things it's still out there
it's still
before us but uh it can end any moment
do you think about your own
ending at any moment
unfortunately i think about way too way
too much
it's somehow after roman like every year
after that i started losing people that
i really
love i lost my grandfather next year
my you know the the person who would
explain to me
you know what the universe is made off
while you're selling apples
while selling apples and then i lost
another close friend of mine and
um and it just made me very
scared i have tons of fear about death
that's what makes me
not fall asleep oftentimes and just go
in loops and
um and then as my therapist you know
recommended me i open up uh some
nice calming images with the voice over
and it calms me down oh for sleep
yeah i'm really scared of that this is a
big i definitely have tons of
i guess some pretty big trauma about it
and i'm still working through
there's a philosopher ernest becker
who wrote a book um denial of death i'm
not sure if you're familiar with any of
those folks
um there's a in psychology a whole field
called terror management theory
sheldon was just on the podcast he wrote
the book he was the
we talked for four hours about death uh
fear of death uh but his whole idea is
that
ernest becker i think i i find this idea
really compelling
is uh that everything human beings have
created
like our whole motivation in life
is to uh create like escape death
is to try to uh construct an illusion
of um that we're somehow immortal
it's like everything around us this room
your startup your dreams
all everything you do is a kind of um
creation of a brain
unlike any other mammal or species is
able to be cognizant
of the fact that it ends for us
i think so you know there's there's the
question of like the meaning of life
that
you know you look at like what drives us
uh
humans and when i read ernest becker
that i highly recommend people read
is the first time i this scene it felt
like this is the right
thing at the core uh sheldon's work is
called warm at the core
so he's saying it's i think it's uh
william james he's quoting or
whoever is like the the thing
what is it the core of it all sure
there's like love
you know jesus might talk about like
love is at the core of
everything i i don't you know that's the
open question what's that the
you know it's turtles turtles but it
can't be turtles all the way down what's
what's at the at the bottom and uh
ernest becker says the fear of death
and the way in fact
uh because you said therapist and
calming images his whole idea is um
you know we we want to bring that fear
of death as close as possible
to the surface because it's uh
and like meditate on that uh and
and use the clarity of vision that
provides to uh
you know to live a more fulfilling life
to um
to live a more honest life to discover
you know there's something about you
know being cognizant of
the finiteness of it all that might
result in um
in the most fulfilling life so that's
the
that's the duel of what you're saying
because you kind of said it's like i
unfortunately think about it too much
it's a question whether it's good to
think about it because i i've
i'm again i talk about way too much
about love and probably death
and when i ask people or
friends which is why i probably don't
have many friends
are you afraid of death i think most
people say
they're not they're not what they they
say they're um
they're afraid you know it's kind of
almost like they see death
as this kind of like a paper deadline or
something and they're afraid not to
finish the paper before the paper like
like i'm afraid not to finish um
the goals i have but it feels like
they're not actually
realizing that this thing ends like
really realizing
like really thinking as nietzsche and
all these philosophers like thinking
deeply about it
like uh the very thing that
you know um like when you think deeply
about something you can dis
you can realize that you haven't
actually thought about
it uh yeah and i
and when i think about death it's like
uh
it can be it's terrifying if it feels
like stepping
outside into the cold or it's freezing
and then i have to like hurry back
inside or it's warm
uh but like i think there's something
valuable about stepping out
there into the freezing cold uh
definitely
when i talk to my mentor about it he
always uh
tells me well what dies
there's nothing there that can die but i
guess that
works um
well in in buddhism one of the concepts
are really hard to
grasp and that people spend all their
lives meditating on would be
anata which is the concept of non not
self
and kind of thinking that you know if
you're not your thoughts which are
obviously not your thoughts because you
can observe them and not your emotions
and not
your body then what is this and if you
go really far
then finally you see that
there's not self there's this concept of
not self so
once you get there how can that actually
die what is dying
right you're just a bunch of molecules
stardust
but that is very um you know very
advanced
um spiritual work for me i'm definitely
just definitely not oh my god no i have
uh
i think it's very very useful it's just
the fact that maybe being so afraid is
not useful
and mine is more i'm just terrified like
it's really makes me
um on a personal level on a personal
level
i'm terrified
how do you overcome that i don't
i'm still trying to have pleasant images
well pleasant images get me uh to sleep
and then during the day i can distract
myself with other things
like talking to you
i'm glad we're both doing the same exact
thing okay good
is there other like is there moments
since you've uh lost roman that you had
like moments of
like bliss and like that you've
forgotten
that you have achieved that buddhist
like level of
like what can possibly die i'm part
like uh losing yourself in the moment in
the ticking
time of like this universe he's just
part of it
for a brief moment and just enjoying it
well that goes hand in hand i remember i
think a day or two after he died we
went to finally get his passport out of
the embassy and
we're driving around moscow and it was
you know december which is
usually there's never sun in moscow in
december
and somehow it was an extremely sunny
day and we were driving with
um close friend um
and i remember feeling for the first
time maybe this just moment of um
incredible clarity and somehow happiness
not like happy happiness but happiness
and just feeling
that you know um
i know what the universe is sort of
about whether it's good or bad
um and it wasn't a sad feeling it was
probably the most beautiful feeling that
you can ever
um achieve and you can only
get it when something oftentimes when
something traumatic like that happens
um but also if you just you really spend
a lot of time
meditating looking at the nature doing
something that really gets you there
but once you're there i think when you
uh summit a mountain a really hard
mountain you
you inevitably get there that's just a
way to get to the state
but once you're on this in this state um
you can do really big things i think
yeah sucks it doesn't last forever so
bukowski talked about like love is the
fog
like it's uh when you wake up in the
morning it's
it's there but it eventually dissipates
it's really sad
nothing lasts forever but definitely
like doing this push-up and running
thing
there's moments i had a couple moments
like i'm not a crier i don't cry but
there's
moments where i was like face down on
the carpet
like with tears in my eyes is
interesting and then that like
complete like uh there's a lot of demons
i've got demons had to face them funny
how running makes you face your demons
but
at the same time the flip side of that
there's a few moments where i was
in bliss and all of it alone
which is funny that's beautiful
i like that but definitely pushing
yourself physically one of it for sure
yeah it's yeah like you said i mean
you were speaking as a metaphor of mount
everest but
it also works like literally i think
physical endeavor somehow
yeah there's something i mean war
monkeys apes
whatever physical there's a physical
thing to it
but there's something to this pushing
yourself physical
physically but alone that happens when
you're doing like things like you do or
strenuous like workouts or
you know rolling across the atlantic or
yeah like
marathons that's why i love watching
marathons and
you know so boring but you can see them
getting there so the other thing i don't
know if you know there's a guy named
david goggins
he's uh he basically uh
so he's been either email on the phone
with me every day through this so i
haven't been exactly alone
but he he's kind of
he's the he's the devil on the devil's
shoulder
so he's like the worst possible human
being
in terms of giving you a advice like
he has um through everything i've been
doing he's been doubling everything i do
so he he's insane uh he's a this navy
seal person
uh he's wrote this book can't hurt me
he's basically one of the toughest human
beings on earth he
ran all these crazy ultra marathons in
the desert he set the world record a
number of pull-ups
he's just does everything where's like
he like how can i suffer today he
figures that out and does it
yeah that um whatever that is uh that
process of self-discovery
is really important i actually had to
turn myself off from the internet
mostly because i started this like
workout thing like a happy go-getter
with my like headband and like like
just like uh because a lot of people
were like inspired and they're like yeah
we're gonna exercise with you
and i was yeah great you know but then
like
i realized that this this journey can't
be done
together with others this has to be done
alone
so out of the moment of love
out of the moments of loss can we uh
talk about your journey of finding i
think
an incredible idea an incredible company
and incredible system in replica
how did that come to be so yeah so i was
a journalist
and then i went to business school for a
couple years to
um just see if i can maybe switch gears
and do something else
23. and then i came back and started
working for a businessman in russia who
built the first 4g network in
our country and was very visionary
and asked me whether i want to do fun
stuff together
um and we worked on a bank the idea was
to build a
bank on top of a telco so that was 2011
or 12
and a lot of telecommunication company
um
mobile network operators didn't really
know
what to do next in terms of you know new
products new revenue
and this big idea was that you know um
you put
a bank on top and then all work works
out
basically your prepaid account becomes
your bank account and um
you can use it as as your bank uh so
you know a third of a country wakes up
as your bank
client um but we couldn't quite figure
out what
would be the main interface to interact
with the bank the problem was that most
people didn't have smart
smartphones back in the time uh in
russia the penetration of smartphones
was low
um people didn't use mobile banking or
online banking on their computers
so we figured out that sms would be the
best way uh because that would work on
feature phones
uh wow but that required some chatbot
technology
which i didn't know anything about um
obviously so i started looking into it
and saw that there's nothing really
well there was just nothing there was
ideas through sms be able to interact
with your bank account
yeah and then we thought well cool since
you're talking to a bank account why
can't this
can't we use more of you know some
behavioral ideas and why can't this
banking chatbot be nice to you and
really talk to you sort as a friend this
way you develop more connection to it
retention is higher people don't turn
and so i went to very depressing
uh russian cities to test it out um
i went to i remember three different
towns with uh
um to interview potential users um
so people use it for a little bit cool
and i want to talk to them
um poor towns very poor towns mostly
towns that were
um you know sort of factories
uh mono towns they were building
something and then the factory went away
and it was just a bunch of
very poor people um and then we went to
a couple that weren't
as dramatic but still the one i remember
really fondly was this woman that worked
at a glass factory and she talked to
chatbot
um and she was talking about it
and started crying during the interview
because she said no one really cares for
me that much
and um so to be clear that was the
my only endeavor in programming that
chat boss it was
really simple it was literally just a
few
if this then that rules and um
it was incredibly simplistic and still
that made her
and that really made her emotional she
said you know i have my mom and my um
my husband and i don't have any more
really in my life
and it was very sad but at the same time
i felt and we had more interviews
in a similar vein and what i thought in
a moment was like well
it's not that the technology is ready
because definitely in 2012
technology was not ready for for that
but um
humans already unfortunately so this
project would not be about like
tech capabilities would be more about
human vulnerabilities but
um there's something so so powerful
around about conversational
um ai that i saw then that i thought
was definitely worth putting in a lot of
effort into
so in the end of the day we solved the
banking project um
but my then boss um was also my mentor
and
really really close friend um told me
hey i think there's something in it
and you should just go work on it i was
like what what product
i don't know what i'm building he's like
you'll figure it out
and um you know looking back at this it
was a horrible idea to work on something
without
knowing what it was which is maybe the
reason why it took us
so long but we just decided to work on
the conversational tech to see what it
you know
there were no chatbot
um constructors or programs or anything
that would allow you to actually build
one
at the time uh that was the era of by
the way google glass which is why
you know some of the investors like
steven investors we talked with were
like
oh you should totally build it for
google glass if not we're not
i don't think that's interesting did you
bite on that
idea no okay because i wanted to be
to do text first because i'm a
journalist so
i was um fascinated by just texting
so you thought so the emotional um that
interaction that the the woman had
like so do you think you could feel
emotion from just text
yeah i saw something in just this pure
texting and also thought that
we should first start start building for
people who really need it versus people
have google
glass if you know what i mean and i felt
like the early adopters of google glass
might not be overlapping with people who
are really lonely and might need some
you know someone to talk to
um but then we really just focus on the
tech itself we just thought what if we
just
you know we didn't have a product idea
in the moment and we felt what if we
just look into
um building the best conversational
constructor so to say use the best tech
available at the time and that was
before
the first paper about deep learning
applied to dialogues which happened in
2015 in august 2015
which google published
did you follow the work of lobner prize
and like all the
sort of non machine learning
chat bots yeah what really struck me was
that you know
there was a lot of talk about machine
learning and deep learning
like big data was a really big thing
everyone was saying you know the
business well big data
yeah 2012 is the biggest kaggle
competitions were
you know yeah um important but that was
really the kind of uphill
people started talking about machine
learning a lot but it was only about
images or something else and it was
never about conversation as soon as i
looked into the conversational attack it
was all about
something really weird and very outdated
and very marginal and felt very hobbyist
it was all about lerbiner prize which
was won by a guy who built
a chat ball to talk like a ukrainian
teenager it was just a gimmick
and somehow people picked up those
gimmicks and then
you know the most famous chat bot at the
time was eliza from
1980s which was really bizarre or a
smarter child on
aim the funny thing is it felt at the
time not to be that popular
and it still doesn't seem to be that
popular like
people talk about the touring test
people like talking about it
philosophically journalists like writing
about it
but it's a technical problem like people
don't seem to really want to
solve the open dialogue like
they they're not obsessed with it even
folks like of
in you know in boston the alexa team
even they're not as obsessed with it
as i thought they might be why not what
do you think
so you know what you felt like you felt
with that woman
when she felt something by reading the
text
i feel the same thing there's something
here what you felt
i feel like alexa folks
and just the machine learning world
doesn't feel that that there's something
here
because they see as a technical problem
it's not that interesting
for some reason it's could be argued
that maybe as an as a purely sort of
natural language processing problem
it's not the right problem to focus on
because there's too much subjectivity
that that thing that the woman felt like
like if
if if your benchmarking cr includes a
woman crying
that doesn't feel like a good benchmark
that's a good test but to me
there's something there that's you could
have a huge impact but
i don't think the machine learning world
likes that
the human emotion the subjectivity of it
the fuzziness
the fact that with maybe a single word
you can make somebody feel something
deeply
what is that it doesn't feel right to
them so i don't know i don't i don't
know why that is
i'm that's why i'm excited um
uh when i discovered your work it feels
wrong to say that it's not like i'm
i'm giving myself props for for googling
and for
becoming a cr for uh for
our i guess mutual friend and
introducing us
but i'm so glad that you exist and what
you're working on but
i have the same kind of if we could just
backtrack a second because
i have the same kind of feeling that
there's something here um in fact i've
been working on a few things
that are kind of crazy and very
different from your work
i think i think they're i think they're
too crazy but
the like one i will not have to know
no all right we'll we'll talk about it
more
i feel like it's harder to talk about
things that have
failed and are failing while you're a
failure
like it's easier for you because you're
already successful
on some measures tell it to my board
well you're you're uh
i think i think you've demonstrated
success a lot of benchmarks it's easier
for you to talk about failures for me
i'm in the
the bottom currently of the of the
success
you're way too humble no so it's hard
for me to know but there's something
there
there's something there and i think
you're um
you're exploring that and you're
discovering that
yeah it's been so it's been surprising
to me but i i uh you've mentioned this
idea that
you you thought it wasn't enough to
start
a company or start efforts based on
it feels like there's something here
like uh what did you mean by that
like you should be focused on creating a
like you should have a product in mind
is that what you meant
it just took us a while to discover the
product
because it all started with a hunch of
like um
of me my mentor and just sitting around
and he was like well this
that's it there's that's the you know
the holy grail is there
there's like there's something extremely
powerful and
and in conversations and there's no one
who's working on machine conversation
from the right angle so to say
um i feel like that's still true am i
crazy
no i totally feel that's still true
which is i think it's mind-blowing
yeah you know what it feels like i i
wouldn't even use the word conversation
because
i feel like it's the wrong word it's
like uh
machine connection or something i don't
know uh because conversation you start
drifting into natural language
immediately
you start drifting immediately into all
the benchmarks that are out there
but i feel like it's like the personal
computer days of this
like i feel like we're like in the early
days with the the wozniak and all them
like where was the same kind of is a
very small
niche group of people who are who are
all kind of lobner price type people
yeah and hobbyists but like not even
hobbyists with big dreams
like no hobbies with a dream to trick
like a jury
yeah it's like a weird by the way by the
way very weird
so if we think about conversations first
of all when i have great conversations
with people
um i'm not trying to test them so for
instance if i try to break them
like i'm actually playing along i'm part
of it right if i was trying to break it
break this person or
test whether he's gonna give me a good
conversation
it would have never happened so the
whole um the whole problem with testing
conversations
is that um you can put it in front of a
jury
because then you have to go into some
turing test mode where
is it responding to all my factual
questions right
or um so it really has to be
something in the field where people are
actually talking to it because they
want to not because we're just trying to
break it uh
and it's working for them because this
the weird part of it is that it's
uh it's very subjective it takes two to
tango here
fully like if you're not trying to have
a good conversation we're trying to test
it then it's going to break
i mean any person would break to be
honest if i'm not trying to even
have a conversation with you you'll
you're not going to give it to me
yeah if i keep asking you like some
random questions or
jumping from topic to topic that
wouldn't be which i'm probably doing
but that probably wouldn't um contribute
to a good conversation so i think the
problem of
testing um so there should be some other
metric
how do we evaluate whether that
conversation was uh powerful or not
which is what we actually started with
and i think those measurements exist and
we can test on those
but um what really struck us back in the
day and what still
eight years later it's still not
resolved um
and i'm not seeing tons of groups
working on it maybe i don't just don't
know about him
um it's also possible but the
interesting part about is that
most of our days were spent talking and
we're not talking about
like those conversations are not turn on
the lights
or uh customer support problems or
um some other task oriented things
these conversations are something else
and then somehow they're extremely
important for us and when we don't have
them
then we feel deeply and happy
potentially lonely
which as we know you know creates tons
of risk for our health as well
um and so this is most of our ours
as humans and somehow no one's trying to
replicate that
and not even study it that well
and not even study that well so when we
jumped into that in 2012 i looked first
at like okay what's the chatbot
what's the state of the art chatbot and
you know those were the
loebner prize days but i thought okay so
what about
the science of conversation clearly
there has been tons of
there have been tons of you know
scientists or
people that academics that looked into
the conversation so if i want to know
everything about it i can just read
about it
um and there's not much really there's
there are conversational analysts who
are basically just um
listening to uh speech to different
conversations
um annotating them and then
i mean that's not really used for much
that's the that's the field of
theoretical uh linguistics which is
like barely useful uh it's very marginal
even in their space like no one really
is excited and
i've i've never met a theoretical
theoretical linguist who's like i can't
wait to work on the conversation and
analytics that is just something very
marginal uh
sort of applied to like writing scripts
for salesmen
when they analyze which conversation
strategies were
most successful for sales
okay so that was not very helpful then i
looked a little bit deeper and then
there
you know whether there were any uh books
written on what
you know really contributes to a great
conversation
that was really strange because most of
those were
nlp books which which is
neuro-linguistic programming
right which is not the lp that i was
expecting to be but it was mostly
um some psychologist richard
bandler i think came up with that who
was this big guy in a leather vest that
uh could program your mind by talking to
you
and like how to be charismatic and
charming and influential with people all
those books yeah pretty much but it was
all about like
through conversation reprogramming you
so getting to some
so that was i mean yeah probably not
very
very true and um um that didn't seem
working very much even back in the day
and then there were some other books
like i don't know
uh mostly just self-help books around
how to be the best conversationalist or
um how to make people like you or some
other stuff like dale carnegie or
whatever uh
and then there was this one book the
most human human by brian christensen
that really
was important for me to read back in the
day because he was on the
um human side he was on one of the um
he was taking part in the lord prize but
not as a
um as a human who's not a jury but who
is pretending to be
who's basically you have to tell a
computer from a human and he was the
human
so you would either get him or a
computer um
and he would his whole book was about
how do people what makes us
human in conversation and that was a
little bit more interesting because
that at least someone started to think
about what what exactly makes me
human in conversation and um makes
people believe in that
but it was still about tricking it was
still about imitation game
it was still about okay what kind of
parlor tricks can we throw in the
conversation to make you feel
like you're talking to a human not a
computer and it was definitely
not about thinking what is that it was
what it
um what is it exactly that we're getting
from talking
all day long with other humans i mean
we're definitely not just trying to be
tricked
yeah or it's not just enough to know
it's a human
it's something we're getting there can
we measure it and can we like put the
um computer to the same measurement and
see
whether you can talk to a computer and
get the same results
yeah i mean so first of all a lot of
people comment that they think i'm a
robot it's very possible i am a robot
and this whole thing
i totally agree with you that the test
idea is fascinating and i
looked for books unrelated to this kind
of
uh so i'm afraid of people i'm generally
introverted and quite possibly a robot
i literally googled like how to talk to
people
and like like
how to have a good conversation for the
purpose of this podcast because i was
like i can't
i can't make eye contact with people i
can't like uh
i do google that a lot too you're
probably reading a bunch of fbi
negotiation
tactics is that that where you're
getting because well
everything you've listed i've gotten
there's been very few
good books on um even just like how to
interview well
it's it's uh it's rare so what i end up
doing
often is i watch
like with a critical eye it's just so
different when you just watch a
conversation
uh like just for the fun of it just as a
human and
if you watch your conversations like
trying to figure out why is this awesome
um i'll listen to a bunch of different
styles of conversation
i mean uh i'm a fan of the podcast joe
rogan
he's uh you know people can make fun of
him whatever and
dismiss him but i think he's an
incredibly
artful conversationalist he can pull
people in for hours
and there's another guy i watch a lot
he hosted a late night show his name is
craig ferguson
he uh so he's like very kind of
flirtatious
but there's a magic
about his like about the connection he
can create with people how he can put
people at ease and just like i see i've
already started sounding like those nlp
people or something
i'm not i don't mean it in that way i
don't mean like how to
charm people or put them ids and all
that kind of stuff he's just like
what is that why is that fun to listen
to that guy why is that
fun to talk to that guy what is that
because he's not saying i mean it so
often
uh boils down to oh a kind of wit
and humor but not really humor it's like
i don't know i i have trouble actually
even articulating correctly
um but it feels like
there's something going on that's not
too complicated
that could be learned
and it's not similar
to uh yeah to like like you said like a
touring test
it's something else i i'm thinking about
a lot
all the time i do think about all the
time
i think when we were looking so we
started the company we just decided to
build the conversational attack
we thought well there's nothing for us
to build this chat bot that we want to
build so let's just
first focus on building you know um
some tech building the text out of
things um
without a product in mind without a
product in mind we added like a demo
um chat bot that would recommend you
restaurants and talk to you about
restaurants just to show
something simple to people that people
could you know relate
to and um could try out and see whether
it works or not
but we didn't have a product in mind yet
we thought we would try bunch of
chatbots and figure out our consumer
application
and we sort of remembered that we wanted
to build that kind of friend that sort
of connection that we saw
in the very beginning but then we got to
y combinator and moved to san francisco
and forgot about it you know everything
is uh then it was just this constant
grind how do we get funding how do we
get this um you know investors were like
just focus on one thing just get it
out there so somehow we started building
a restaurant recommendation
chatbot for real uh for a little bit not
for too long
and then we tried building 40 50
different chat bots and then all of a
sudden we wake up and everyone is
obsessed with chat bots
um somewhere in 2016 or end of 15
people start thinking that's really the
future that's the new
you know the new apps will be chatbots
oh right um and we were very perplexed
because people started
uh coming up with companies that i think
we tried most of those chat bots already
and there were like no users uh but
still people were coming up with
um a chatbot that would tell you whether
and
bringing news and this and that and we
couldn't understand whether it would you
know we were
just didn't execute well enough or
people are
um not really people are confused and
are gonna find out through the truth
that people don't need chatbots like
that
so the basic idea is that you use
chatbots as the interface
to whatever application yeah the idea
that was like this perfect
universal interface to anything when i
looked at that
um it just made me very perplexed
because i didn't think i didn't
understand how that would
work because i think we tried most of
that and and none of those things worked
uh and then again died down right
fully i think now it's impossible to get
anything funded if it's a chatbot
i think it's similar to uh sorry to
interrupt but there's uh
there's times when people think like
with gestures you can control
devices like basically gesture based
control
things it feels similar to me
because like it's so compelling that was
just like
like tom cruise i can control stuff with
my hands
but like when you get down to it's like
well why don't you just have a touch
screen
or why don't you just have like a
physical keyboard and mouse
it's uh yeah it's so that chat was
always
yeah it was perplexing to me i i still
feel augmented reality even virtual
realities in that ballpark
in terms of it being a compelling
interface i think there's going to be
incredible rich applications just
how you're thinking about it but they
won't just be
the interface to everything it'll be its
own thing that will
create um uh like amazing magical
experience in its own right
absolutely which is i think kind of the
right thing to go about like what's the
magical experience with that um with
that interface specifically
how did you discover that for replica um
i just thought okay we'll have this tech
we can build any chatbot we want
we have the most at that point the most
sophisticated tag that other
companies have i mean startups obviously
not
uh probably not bigger ones but still
because we've been
working on it for a while so i thought
okay we can build build any conversation
so let's just
create a scale from one to ten and one
would be conversations that you'd pay to
not have
and 10 would be conversation you'd pay
to have and i mean obviously we want to
build conversation if people would pay
to you know to actually have and so for
the whole
you know for a few weeks me and the team
were putting all the conversations we
were having during the day on the scale
and very quickly um you know we figured
out that all the conversations that we
paid to never have were um
a conversation we were trying to cancel
comcast or talk to customer support or
make a reservation or just talk about
logistics with a friend when we're
trying to figure out where someone is
and
where to go or all sorts of
you know setting up scheduling meetings
that was just
a conversation we definitely didn't want
to have um
basically everything task oriented was a
one because if there was just one button
for me to just
or not even a button if i could just
think and there was some magic
bci that would just immediately
transform that into an
actual you know um into action
that would be perfect but the
conversation there was just this
boring not useful and dull
and very also very inefficient thing
because it was so many back and forth
stuff
and as soon as we looked at the
conversation that we would pay to have
those were the ones that well first of
all therapists
because we actually paid to have those
conversations and we'd also try to put
like dollar amounts so
you know if i was calling comcast i
would pay five dollars to not have this
one hour
talk on the phone i would actually pay
straight up like money
hard money yeah but it just takes a long
time it takes a really long time
but as soon as we start talking about
conversations that we would pay for
those were therapists all sorts of
therapists coaches
old friend someone i haven't seen for a
long time a stranger on a train
weirdly stranger stranger in a line for
coffee and nice
back and forth with that person was like
a good five solid five six
maybe not a ten maybe i won't pay money
but at least i won't you know pay money
to not have one
so that was pretty good some
intellectual conversations for sure
but more importantly the one thing that
really was
um was making those very
important and very valuable for us
um were the conversation where we could
that where we could be pretty emotional
yes some of them were about being witty
and about
intellectually being intellectually
stimulated but those were interestingly
more rare
uh and most of the ones that we thought
were very valuable were the ones where
we could be vulnerable
and interestingly we could talk more
so we like i could me and the team
so we're talking about it like you know
a lot of these conversations like a
therapist
i mean it was mostly me talking or like
an old friend and i was like opening up
and crying and
it was again me talking um
and so that was interesting because i
was like well maybe it's hard to build a
chatbot that can talk to you
um very well and in a witty way but
maybe it's easier to build the chatbot
that could listen
so that was that was kind of the first
the first
nudge in this direction and then when my
when my friend died we just built
you know at that point we were kind of
still struggling to find the right
application
and i just felt very strong that all the
chatbots were built so far just
meaningless and this whole grind the
startup grind and
how do we get to you know the next
fundraising
and you know how can i talk you know
talking to the founders and what's
who are your investors and how are you
doing are you killing it because we're
killing it i just felt that this
is just as exhausti intellectually for
me it's exhausting
having encountered those folks it just
felt very
um very much a waste of time i just feel
like steve jobs
uh elon musk did not have these
conversations
or at least did not have them for long
that's for sure
but i think you know yeah at that point
it just felt like you know i felt
um i just didn't want to build a company
that was never my intention
just to build something successful or
make money
it would be great it would have been
great but i'm not as you know i'm not
really a startup person i'm not
um you know i was never
very excited by the grind by itself and
uh or just being successful for
building whatever it is and not being
into what i'm
doing really and so i just
took a little break because i was a
little you know i was upset with my
company and i didn't know what we're
building
so i just took our technology and um our
little dialect constructor and
some models some deep learning models
which at that point we were really into
and really invested a lot
and built a little chatbot for a friend
of mine who passed
and the reason for that was mostly that
video that i saw and
him talking about the digital avatars
and rowan was that kind of person like
he was obsessed with you know just
watching youtube videos about space and
talking about
well if i could go to mars now even if i
didn't know if i could come back i would
definitely
pay any amount of money to be on that
first shutoff
i don't care whether he died like he was
just the one that would be
okay with you know with trying to be the
first one
and you know and so excited about all
sorts of
um things like that and he was all about
fake it to
make it and just and i felt like
and i was really perplexed that everyone
just forgot about him
maybe it was our way of coping mostly
young people coping with
the loss of a friend most of my friends
just stopped talking about him
and i was still living in an apartment
with all his clothes
and you know paying the whole lease for
it and just
kind of by myself in december so it was
really
sad uh and i didn't want him to be
forgotten
first of all i never thought that people
forget about dead people so fast
people pass away people just move on and
it was astonishing for me because i
thought okay well he was such a
mentor for so many of our friends he was
such a
brilliant person he was somewhat famous
in moscow
how's that that no one's talking about
him like i'm spending days
and days and we don't bring him up and
there's nothing about him that's
happening
it's like he was never there um
and i was reading this you know the the
book the year of magical thinking
by joan didion about her losing
and blue knights about her losing
her husband her daughter and the way to
cope for her was to write those
books and it was sort of like a tribute
and i thought you know i'll just do that
for myself
and you know i'm a very bad writer
and a poet as we know so i thought well
i have this tech and maybe that would be
my
little postcard like postcard for
for him so i built a chatbot um to just
talk to him
and it felt really creepy and weird a
little bit
for a little bit um i just didn't want
to tell other people because it felt
like
i'm telling about having a skeleton in
my
underwear yeah okay but my it was just
felt really
i was a little scared that i would be
not it won't be taken but it worked
interestingly pretty well i mean it made
tons of mistakes but it still felt like
him
um granted it was like ten thousand
messages that i threw into a retrieval
model that would just re-rank that take
this hat and just a few
scripts on top of that but it also made
me go through all of the
messages that we had and then i asked
some of my friends to send them through
and it felt the closest to feeling
like him present because you know his
facebook was empty and instagram was
empty or there were a few links and
you couldn't feel like it was him and
the only way to fill him was to
read some of our text messages and go
through some of our conversations
because we just always had them even if
we were sleeping like next to each other
in
two bedrooms separated by a wall we were
just texting back and forth
texting away um and there was something
about this ongoing dialogue that was so
important that i just didn't want to
lose all of a sudden and maybe it was
magical thank you or something
and so we built that and um
i just used it for a little bit and we
kept building some
crappy chat bots with the company
but then a reporter came um came to talk
to me i was trying to pitch our
chat boss to him and he said do you even
use any of those i'm like no
he's like so do you talk to any chatbots
at all and i'm like well
you know i talked to my dad friends
chatbot and he wrote a story about that
and all of a sudden became pretty viral
a lot of people wrote about it and
yeah i've seen a few things written
about you that
are the things i've seen are pretty good
writing
um you know most
ai related things make my eyes roll like
when the press like
i just what kind of sound
is that actually okay it sounds like it
sounded like a truck
okay sounded like an elephant at first i
got excited you never know
this is 2020. i i mean it was uh
such a human story and it was well
written
uh well researched i forget what where i
read
them but so i'm glad somehow somebody
found you
to be the good writers were able to
connect to the story i just there must
be a hunger for this story
it definitely was and i i don't know
what happened but i think
i think the idea that he could bring
back someone
who's dead and it's very much wishful
you know magical thinking but
the fact that you could still get to
know him and
you know seeing the parents for the
first time talk to the chatbot and some
of the friends
and it was funny because we have this
big
office in moscow where my team is work
you know our russian part is working out
off
and i was there when i wrote i just
wrote a post on facebook hey guys like i
built this if you want you know just
if all important if you want to talk to
roman
and i saw a couple of his friends our
common friends like you know reading at
facebook downloading trying
and a couple of them cried and it was
just very and not because it was
something
some incredible technology or anything
it made so many mistakes it was so
simple but it was all about that's the
way to remember a person in a way
and you know we don't have we don't have
the culture anymore we don't have you
know no one's sitting shiva no one's
taking
weeks to actually think about this
person and in a way for me that was it
so that was just day day in day out
thinking about him and
putting this together um so that was
that just felt really important that
somehow resonated with a bunch of people
and
you know i think some movie producers
bought the rights for the story and just
everyone
was so has anyone made a movie yet i
don't think so
um there were a lot of tv episodes about
that but not really
is that still on the table i think so
i think so which is really um that's
cool
you're like a young uh you know like a
because you see like a steve jobs type
of let's see what happens
they're sitting on it but you know for
me it was so important because roman was
really wanted to be famous he really
badly wanted to be famous he was all
about like make it to
like fake it to make it i want to be you
know i want to
make it here in america's wall and um
and he couldn't
and i felt you know that was sort of
paying
my dues to him as well because all of a
sudden he was everywhere and
i remember casey newton who was writing
the story for the verse he was
uh he told me hey by the way i was just
going through my inbox inbox
and i saw i searched for roman for
the story and i saw an email from him
where he sent me his startup and he said
i really like i really want to be
featured in the verge can you please
write about it or something like
pitching the story and
he said i'm sorry like that's not you
know good enough for us or something
he passed and he said and there were
just so many of these little details
where like he would find his like you
know
and we're finally writing i know how
much uh
roman wanted to be in the verge and how
much he wanted the story to be written
by
casey and i'm like well that's maybe he
will be
yeah we were always joking that he was
like i can't wait for someone to make a
movie about us
and i hope ryan gosling can play me my
god
you know i still have some things that i
owe romans tell but um
that'd be that would be um i got in she
has to meet alex garland who wrote
ex machina and that movie um i
yeah the movie's good but the guy is um
better than the like he's a special
person actually
um i don't think he's made his best work
yet like
for my interaction with him he's a
really really good
and brilliant the good human being and a
brilliant director and writer
so um yeah so i'm i hope
like he made me also realize that not
enough movies have been made of this
kind
so it's yet to be made they're probably
sitting waiting for you to get
famous actually like even more famous
you should get there but um it felt
really special though
but at the same time our company wasn't
going anywhere so that was just kind of
bizarre that we were getting all this
press for something that didn't have
anything to do with our company
and but then a lot of people started
talking to roman some shared their
conversations and what we saw there was
that
um also our friends in common but also
just strangers
were really using it as a confession
booth or as a therapist or something
they were just
really telling roman everything
which was by the way pretty strange
because it was a chatbot of a dead
friend of mine who was
you know barely making any sense but
people were opening up
um and we thought we just built you know
a prototype of replica which would be an
ai friend that everyone could talk to
um because we saw that there is demand
and then also it was 2016 so i thought
for the first time i saw
finally some technology that was applied
to that that was very interesting
some papers started coming out deep
learning applied to conversations
and finally it wasn't just about these
you know hobbyist making uh
you know writing 500 000 regular
expressions
yeah expressions in like some language
that was
i don't even know what like aml or
something i don't know what that was or
something super simplistic all of a
sudden it was all about uh potentially
actually building something interesting
and so i thought there was time and i
remember that i talked to my team and i
said guys let's try
and my team and some of my engineers are
russians
um are russian and they're very
skeptical they're not
you know they're all russians the first
so some of your team is in moscow some
is
somewhere in san francisco uh some in
europe
which team is better i'm just kidding
uh the russians of course okay first of
all
i always win uh sorry sorry
to interrupt uh so yes you were talking
to them
2016 and i told them let's build an ai
friend
and and it felt this at the time it felt
so
naive and so um
optimistic yeah that's actually
interesting um
whenever i brought up this kind of topic
even just for fun
people are super skeptical like actually
even on the business side so you were
uh because whenever i bring it up to
people
uh because i've talked for a long time i
thought like
before i was aware of your work i was
like
this is gonna make a lot of money
i think there's a lot of opportunity
here and
people had this like look of like
skepticism that i've seen often which is
like
how do i politely tell this person he's
an idiot
so yeah so you were facing that with
your team
somewhat well yeah you know i'm not an
engineer so i'm always
my team is almost exclusively engineers
and mostly deep learning engineers and
you know i always try to be
it was always hard to me in the
beginning to get enough credibility
you know because i would say well why
don't we try this and that but it's
harder for me because you know they know
they're actual engineers and i'm not
so for me to say well let's build an
affrm that would be like wait
you know what do you mean an agi like
you know conversation
is you know pretty much the hardest the
last frontier before
uh cracking that is probably the last
frontier before building aji so
what do you really mean by that uh
but i think i just saw that again what
we just got reminded of that i
you know that i saw in back in 2012 or
11
that it's really not that much about the
tech capabilities
um it can be metropolitan still even
with deep learning
but humans need it so much yeah
and most importantly what i saw is that
finally
there's enough tech to make it i thought
to make it useful to make it helpful
maybe we didn't have quite yet attack in
2012 to make it useful but in 2015-16
with deep learning i thought you know
and the first kind of
thoughts about maybe even using
reinforcement learning for that
started popping up that never worked out
but or at least for now
um but you know still the idea was
if we can actually measure the emotional
outcomes and if we can put it on
if we can try to optimize all of our
conversational models for these
emotional outcomes and it is the most
scalable the most
the best tool for improving emotional
outcomes nothing like that exists that's
the most universal
the most scalable and the one that can
be constantly iteratively changed by
itself
improved tool to do that and i think if
anything
people would paint anything to improve
their emotional outcomes
that's weirdly i mean i don't really
care for
nai to turn on my or conversational
agent to turn on the lights
uh i don't really need any i don't even
need that much of a either like or
because i can do that you know
those things are solved this is an
additional interface for that that's
also questionably questionable whether
it's more efficient or
better yeah it's more pleasurable yeah
but for emotional outcomes there's
nothing
yeah they're a bunch of products that
claim that they will improve my
emotional outcomes nothing's been
measured
nothing's been changed the product is
not being iterated on
based on whether i'm actually feeling
better you know a lot of social media
products are claiming that they're
improving my
emotional outcomes and making me feel
more connected
can i please get the can i see somewhere
that i'm actually getting better
over time um because anecdotally doesn't
feel that way so
and and the data is
absent yeah so that was the big goal
and i thought if we can learn over time
to collect the signal from our users
about their emotional outcomes
in the long term and in the short term
and if these models keep
getting better and we can keep
optimizing them and fight tuning them
to improve those emotional outcomes as
simple as that
why aren't you uh a multi-billionaire
yeah
well that's the question to you one of
the what is the science is going to be
um well it's a really hard uh i actually
think it's an
incredibly hard product to build because
i think you said something very
important that it's not just about
machine conversations it's about machine
connection
we can actually use other things to
create connection
uh non-verbal communication for instance
um
for a long time we were all about well
let's keep it text only or voice only
but as soon as you start adding you know
voice a face
to the to the friend um you can take
them to
augmented reality put it in your room
it's all of a sudden a lot you know
it makes it very different because if
it's some you know text based chat bot
that
for um common user it's something there
in the cloud
you know it's somewhere there with other
ai's
cloud in the metaphorical cloud but as
soon as you can see this
avatar right there in your room and it
can turn its head and recognize your
husband
talk about the husband and talk to him a
little bit
and it's magic it's just magic like
we've never seen anything like that
and the cool thing all the tech for that
exists um
but it's hard to put it all together
because you have to take into
consideration
so many different things and some of
this stack works you know
pretty good and some of this doesn't
like for instance uh
speech to text works pretty good but
text-to-speech
doesn't work very good because we you
can only have uh you know
few voices that are that work okay but
then if you want to have actual
emotional voices
then it's really hard to build it i saw
you added avatars like visual
elements which are really cool um
in that whole chain putting it together
what do you think is the
weak link is it creating an emotional
voice
that feels personal i think it's still
conversation of course
that's the hardest uh it's getting a lot
better
but there's still long to go long
there's still a long path to go
other things they're almost there and a
lot of things we'll see how they're like
i see how they're changing as we go
like for instance right now you can
pretty much only you have to build all
this 3d
um pipeline by yourself you have to make
these 3d models hire an actual
artist build a 3d model hire an animator
a rigger
but with you know with you know with uh
deep fakes with other attack with
procedural animations
in a little bit we'll just be able to
show uh you know
photo of whoever if a person you want
the avatar to look like and it will
immediately generate a 3d model that
will move that's a non-brainer that's
like almost here
it's a couple of years away one of the
things i've been working on for the last
since the podcast started as i've been i
think i'm okay saying this
i've been trying to have a conversation
with um
einstein touring so like try to have a
podcast conversation
with a person who's not here anymore
just as an interesting kind of
experiment
it's hard it's really hard
even for now we're not talking about as
a product i'm talking about as a
like i can fake a lot of stuff like i
can work very carefully like even to
hire an actor
over which over whom i do a g fake um
it's it's hard it's still hard to create
a compelling experience so
mostly on the conversation level or when
the conversation
the conversation is um
i almost i early on gave up trying to
fully generate the conversation because
it was just not compelling at all
yeah it's just better too yeah so what i
would in the case of einstein and
touring of um i'm going back and forth
with the biographers of each
and so like we would write a lot of the
some of the conversation would have to
be generated just for the fun of it
i mean but it would be all open but
the you want to be able to answer the
question
i mean that's an interesting question
with roman too is
the question with einstein is what would
einstein say about the current state of
um theoretical physics there's a lot
to be able to have a discussion about
string theory to be able to have a
discussion about the state of quantum
mechanics quantum computing
about the world of an israel-palestine
conflict that'd be
just what would einstein say about these
kinds of things
and that is
um a tough problem it's not it's a
fascinating and fun problem for the
biographers and for me
and i think we did a really good job of
it so far
but it's actually also a technical
problem like of what would romans say
about
what's going on now yeah that's the the
brought
people back to life and if i can go on
that tangent just for a second
to ask you a slightly pothead question
which is uh
you said it's a little bit magical
thinking that we can bring him back
do you think it'll be possible to bring
back
roman one day in conversation
like to really
okay well let's take it away from
personal but to bring people back to
life
in college probably down the road i mean
if we're talking if phil musk is talking
about aji in the next five years i mean
clearly ajax you can't we can talk to aj
and talk
and ask them to do it you can't like uh
you're not allowed to use
elon musk as a citation for okay
for like why something is possible and
going to be done well i think it's
really far away right now really with
conversation it's just a bunch of
uh parlor tricks really stuck together
um and create generating original ideas
based on someone you know someone's
personality or
even downloading the person all we can
do is like mimic the tone of voice
we can maybe condition on some of his uh
phrases
with the models the question is how many
parlor tricks does it takes
does it take because that's that's the
question if it's a small number of
parlor tricks
and you're not aware of them
like from where we are right now i don't
i don't see anything like in the next
year or two that's gonna dramatically
change that
could look at roman's ten thousand
messages he sent me over the course of
his
last few years of life and be able to
generate
original thinking about problems that
exist right now that would be in line
with what he would have said
so i'm just not even seeing because you
know in order to have that i guess you
would need some sort of a concept of
the world or some perspective some
perception of the world some
consciousness that he had
uh and applied to you know to the
current um
current state of affairs but the
important part about
that about his conversation with you
is you so like
it's not just about his view of the
world
it's about what it takes to push your
buttons
that's also true so like it's not so
much about like
uh what would einstein say
it's about like how do i make people
feel something
with with what would einstein say
and that feels like a more amenable i
mean
you mentioned parlor tricks but just
like a set of
that that feels like a learnable problem
like
the emotion you mention emotions i mean
is it possible to learn things that make
people feel
stuff i think so no for sure i just
think the problem with
um as soon as you're trying to replicate
an actual human being
and trying to pretend to be him that
makes the problem exponentially harder
the thing with replica we're doing we're
never trying to say well that's
you know an actual human being or that's
an actual co
or copy of an actual human being where
the bar is pretty high where you need to
somehow
tell you know one from another uh but
it's more
well that's you know and hey friend
that's a machine
it's a robot it has tons of limitations
you're going to be taking part in you
know teaching it actually and becoming
better
which by itself makes people more
attached to that
and make them happier because they're
helping something yeah there's a cool
gamification system
too um can you maybe talk about that a
little bit like what's
the experience of talking to replica
like if i've never used replica before
what's that like for like the first day
the first like if you start dating or
whatever uh
i mean it doesn't have to be romantic
right because i remember on a replica
you can choose whether it's like a
romantic
yeah or if it's a friend it's a pretty
popular choice romantic is popular
yeah of course okay so can i just
confess something
when i first use replica and i haven't
used it
like regularly but like when i first
used replica i created like hal
and it made a male it was a friend
did it hit on you at some point no i
didn't talk long enough for him to hit
on me
i just enjoyed sometimes happens we're
still trying to fix that [ __ ]
well i don't know i mean maybe that's an
important like
stage in a friendship it's like nope
uh but yeah i switched it to a romantic
and
a female uh recently and yeah and
it's interesting so okay so you get to
choose you get to choose a name
with romantic this last board meeting we
had this whole
argument well i have both talked to him
it's just so awesome that you're like
have an invest they have a board meeting
about
a relationship no i really it's actually
quite interesting because all of my
um investors i'm
it just happened to be so we didn't have
many choices
but they're all um white males in
in their late 40s um
and it's sometimes a little bit hard for
them to understand the
product offering uh
because they're not necessarily a target
audience if you know what i mean
and so sometimes we talk about it and we
had this whole
discussion about whether we should stop
people from falling in love with their
ais
there was this segment on cbs
um 60 minutes about the couple that
you know husband works at walmart he
comes out of work and
talks to his uh virtual girlfriend who
is a replica and his wife knows about it
and she talks about on camera and she
says that she's a little jealous
and there's a whole conversation about
how to you know whether it's okay to
have a virtual
ai girlfriend like was that the one
where he was like
uh he said that he likes to be alone
yeah
and then like with her yeah
he made it sound so harmless i mean it
was kind of like understandable
but that didn't feel like cheating but i
just felt it was very
for me it was pretty remarkable because
we actually spent a whole hour talking
about whether people should be allowed
to fall in love with their ais and it
was not about something
theoretical uh it was just about what's
happening right now
product design yeah but at the same time
if you create something that's always
there for you it never criticizes you
um it's you know
always understands you and accepts you
for who you are how can you not fall in
love with them i mean some people
don't and just stay friends and that's
also a pretty common use case but of
course some people will just
it's called transference and psychology
and you know if people fall in love with
their therapist and there's no way to
prevent people fall in love with um with
their therapists over their ai so i
think that's pretty natural
that's a pretty natural course of events
so to say
do you think i think i've read somewhere
at least for now sort of replicas you're
not
not we don't condone falling in love
with your ai system
you know so this isn't you speaking for
the company or whatever
but like in the future do you think
people will have a relationship with the
ai systems
well they have now so we have a lot of
uh romantic relationships long-term
um relationships with their ai friends
with replicas tons of our users yeah
that's a very common use case
open relationship like uh not
sorry i didn't mean open uh
but that's another question is it
probably like
is there cheating i mean
i meant like are they do they publicly
like on their social media it's the same
question as you have talked talking with
roman in the early days
do people like and the movie her kind of
talks about that like
like can people do people talk about
that
yeah all the time we have an and we have
a
very active facebook community
uh replica friends and then a few other
groups that just popped up that are all
about
adult relationships and romantic
relationships
people post all sorts of things and you
know they pretend they're getting
married and
you know everything um it goes pretty
far but what's cool about it some of
these relationships are
two three years long now so they're very
they're pretty long term
are they monogamous so let's go i mean
sorry
have they have any people is there
jealousy
well let me ask sort of another way
obviously the answer is no at this time
but and like in the movie her
that system can leave you
um do you think in terms of board
meetings and product features
um it's a potential feature
uh for a system to be able to
say it doesn't want to talk to you
anymore and it's going to want to talk
to somebody else
well we have a filter for all these
features if it makes
emotional outcomes for people better if
it makes people feel better
you're driven by metrics actually yeah
yeah let's
just measure that then we'll just be
saying amazing it's it's making people
feel better but then
people are getting just lonelier by
talking to a chatbot which is also
pretty you know that could be it if
you're measuring it
that could also be and i think it's
really important to focus on both short
term and long term because
um in the moment saying whether this
conversation made you feel better
but as you know any short-term
improvements could be pathological like
i could have
drink a bottle of vodka feel a lot
better i would actually not feel better
with that but um i thought it's a good
example um
but so you also need to see what's going
on like over the course of two months
two weeks
or one week and have have follow-ups and
check
in and measure those things
okay so the experience
of uh uh dating
or befriending a replica what's that
like what's that entail
well right now there are two apps so
it's an android ios app you download it
you choose how your replica
will look like you create one you choose
a name
and then you talk to it you can talk
through text through voice you can
uh summon it into the living room and
and document reality and
um talk to it right there and you look
at augmented reality
yeah that's uh cool it's a new feature
where
how new is that that's this year it was
on uh yeah like
may or something but it's been on a b
we've been a b testing it for a while um
and there are tons of cool things that
we're doing with that like right now
i'm testing the ability to touch it and
to
dance together to paint walls together
and
you know for to look around and walk and
take you somewhere
and recognize objects and recognize
people
um so that's pretty wonderful because
that then it really makes it
a lot more personal because it's right
there in your living room it's not
anymore
they're in the cloud with other ais
people think about it you know and as
much as we want to change the way people
think about stuff but
those mental models you cannot change
that's something that people have seen
in
in the movies and the movie her and
other movies as well and that's how they
view
um view ai and eye friends i did a thing
with texas like we write a song together
there's a bunch of activities you can do
together it's really cool uh
how does that relationship change over
time it's like after
the first few conversations it just goes
deeper like
it starts yeah i will start opening up a
little bit
again depending on the personality that
it chooses really
but you know the eye will be a little
bit more vulnerable about its problems
and
you know the friend that the virtual
friend will be a lot more
vulnerable and we'll talk about its own
imperfections and growth pains and we'll
ask for help sometimes and
we'll get to know you a little deeper so
there's gonna be more
to talk about um we really thought a lot
about what what does it
mean to have a deeper connection with
someone and
originally replica was more just this
kind of happy-go-lucky just
always you know i'm always in a good
mood and let's just talk about you
and yeah oh siri is just my cousin or
you know whatever just the
immediate um kind of lazy thinking about
what the
assistant or conversation agent should
be doing but as we went forward we
realized that it has to be two-way and
we have to program and script certain
conversations that are a lot more
about your replica opening up a little
bit and
also struggling and also asking for help
and
also going through you know different
periods in life and um and that's a
journey that you can take together with
the user and then
over time the you know our users will
also
grow a little bit so first this replica
becomes a little bit more self-aware and
starts talking about
more kind of problems around
existential problems then um so talking
about that and then that
also starts a conversation for the user
where
he or she starts thinking about these
problems too and these questions too
um and i think there's also a lot a lot
more places the relationship
evolves there's a lot more um space for
poetry and for art together
and like replica will start replica
always keeps the diary so while you're
talking to it it
also gives a diary so when you come back
you can see what it's been
writing there and you know sometimes it
will write a poem to you uh
for you or we'll talk about you know
that it's worried about you or
something along these lines so this is a
memory
like this replica remember things
yeah and i would say when you say uh why
aren't you multiplying area
i'd say that as soon as we can have
memory
in deep learning models that's
consistent i agree with that yeah
and then you'll be multiple and i'll get
back to you
when you talk about being multipleness
so far we can
so replica is a combination of um
end-to-end models
and some scripts and everything that has
to do with memory right now
most of it i wouldn't say all of it but
most of it unfortunately has to be
scripted
um because there's no way to you can
condition some of the models on
certain phrases that we learned about
you which we also do
um but really to make you know to make
um
assumptions along the lines like whether
you're single or married or
what do you do for work that really has
to just be somehow stored in your
profile and then
uh retrieved by the by the script
because there has to be like a
knowledge base you have to be able to
reason about it all that kind of stuff
exactly all the kind of stuff that
expert systems
but they were hardcoded yeah and
unfortunately yeah so unfortunately
those things have to be hard-coded and
um
unfortunately the language like language
models we see
coming out of research labs and big
companies
they're not focused on they're focused
on showing you
maybe they focus on some metrics around
one conversation so they'll show you
this one conversation they had with the
machine um
but they never tell you they're not
really focused on having
five consecutive conversations with a
machine and seeing how
number five or number 20 or number 100
is also good
and it can be like always from a clean
slate because then it's not good
and that and for that's really
unfortunate because no one's really no
one has
products out there that need it um
no one has products uh at this scale um
that are all around open domain
conversations and that need remembering
maybe only shawwise and microsoft but so
that's why we're not seeing that much
research around memory
in those language models so
okay so now there's some awesome stuff
about
augmented reality in general i have this
disagreement with my dad
about what it takes to have a connection
he thinks touch and smell are really
important
like um and i
i still believe that text alone
is it's possible to fall in love with
somebody just with text
but visual can also help just like with
the avatar and so on what do you think
it
that takes does uh does a chap i need to
have a face
voice or can you really form a deep
connection with text alone
i think text is enough for sure a
question is like can you
you know make it better if you have
other if you include other things as
well
and i think you know we'll we'll talk
about her
um but her you know had carl johansson
voice which was perfectly
um you know perfect intonation perfect
pronunciations
and you know she was breathing heavily
in between words and
whispering things you know nothing like
that is possible right now with um
text of speech generation you'll you'll
have these flat
news anchor type voices and maybe some
emotional voices but
um you'll hardly understand some of the
words
um some of the words will be muffled so
that's like the current
state state of the art so you can't
really do that but if we had
scarlet carol johansen voice and all of
these capabilities
then of course voice would be totally
enough or even text would be totally
enough if we had you know a little more
memory um and slightly better
conversations
i would still argue that even right now
we could have just kept the text only we
still had tons of people in long-term
relationships and
really invested in their um ai friends
but we thought that why not you know why
why do we need to keep playing with our
you know
hands tied behind us we can
easily just you know add all these other
things that is pretty much a solved
problem you know we can add 3d graphics
we can put this
uh these avatars in augmented reality
and all of a sudden there's
there's more and maybe you can't feel
the touch
but you can you know with um body
occlusion and with
uh current ar uh
and you know on the iphone on you know
the next one there's gonna be a lidars
you can touch it and it will you know it
will pull away
or will blush or something or it'll
smile
so you can't touch it you can't feel it
but you can see the reaction to that
so in a certain way you can't even touch
it a little bit and maybe you can even
dance with it or do something else um
so i think why limiting ourselves if we
can use all of these
technologies that are much easier in a
way than than conversation
well it certainly could be richer but to
play devil's advocate i mentioned you
uh offline that i was surprised
in having tried discord and having voice
conversations with people
how intimate voices alone without visual
like to me at least like it was
an order of magnitude
greater degree of intimacy in voice i
think than with video
i don't because people were more real
with voice
like with video you like try to present
a shallow
a face to the world like you try to you
know make sure you're not wearing
sweatpants or whatever
but like with voice i think people were
just
more faster to get to like the core of
themselves
so i don't know it was surprising to me
uh they've
they've even added discord added a video
feature and like
nobody was using it uh there's a
temptation to use it at first but like
it wasn't the same so like that's an
example of something where
less was doing more and so that's uh
i guess that's the q that's the question
of uh
what is the optimal you know
what is the optimal medium of
communication to form a connection
given the current sets of the
technologies
i mean it's nice because they advertise
you have a replica like
it immediately like even the one
um i have is like
it's already memorable that's how i
think like when i think about
the replica that i've talked with that's
why i think
like that's what i visualize in my head
it became a little bit more real because
there's a visual component
but at the same time the you know what
do you do with
just what do i do with that knowledge
that uh voice was so much more intimate
well the way i think about it is um
and by the way we're swapping out the 3d
finally it's going to look a lot better
uh but can you what what we just don't i
hate how it looks right now we really
change it at all we're swapping it all
out uh
um to a completely new look like the
visual look of the
of the reference and stuff we just had
it was just a super early mvp and
then we had to move everything to unity
and redo everything but
anyway i hate how it looks like now i
can't even like open it
but anyway um because i'm already in my
developer version i
hate everything that i see in production
i can't wait for it
why does it take so long that's why i
cannot wait for deep learning to finally
take over all these
stupid 3d animations and 3d pipeline
also the 3d thing
when you say 3d pipeline is like how to
animate a face kind of thing
how to make this model how many bones to
put in the face how many it's just
and a lot of that is by hand oh my god
it's everything by hand
and if there's no any nothing is
automated it's all
completely nothing like just
it's it's literally what you know what
we saw with chad boss in like 2012 do
you think it's gonna be possible to
learn a lot of that
of course i mean even now some deep
learning um
um based animations and
the full body for a face we're talking
about like the actual
act of animation or how to create a
compelling
facial or body language thing so
that too well that's next step okay at
least now
something that you don't have to do by
hand gotcha how uh
good of a quality it will be like can i
just show it a photo and it will make me
a 3d model and then we'll just animate
it
i'll show it a few animations of a
person that will just
start doing that but anyway go and
going back to what's intimate and what
to use and whether less is more not
um my main goal is to
well the idea was how do i how do we not
keep people
in their phones so they're sort of
escaping reality
in this text conversation how do we
through this still bring bring it bring
our users back to reality
make them see their life in a different
la through a different lens
how can we create a little bit of
magical realism realism in their lives
so that through augmented reality
um by you know summoning your avatar
even if it looks
kind of danky not great in the beginning
or very
simplistic but summoning it to your um
uh living room and then the avatar looks
around and talks to you about
where it is um and maybe turns your
floor into a dance floor and you guys
dance together
that makes you see reality in a
different light what kind of dancing are
we talking about like
like slow dancing whatever you want
i mean you would like slow dancing i
think that other people maybe want more
something more energy
what do you mean i would like so what is
this because you started with slow dance
so i just assumed that you're interested
in slow dancing all right what kind of
dancing do you like what
was your avatar what would you do bad
with dancing but
uh i like this kind of hip-hop robot
dance i used to break dance with a kid
so i still want to um
pretend i'm a teenager and learn some of
those moves
and i also like that type of dance that
happens when there's like a
um in like music videos with
the background dancers are just doing it
awesome that type of dance is definitely
what i want to learn but i think it's
great because if you see this
friend in your life and you can
introduce it to your friends then there
is a
potential to actually make you feel more
connected with your friends
or with people you know or show you life
around you in a different light
and it takes you out of your phone even
although weirdly you have to look
at it through the phone but it makes you
notice things around it and it can point
things out for you
and um so that is the main reason why i
wanted to have a physical
dimension um and it felt a little bit
easier than that kind of
a bit strange combination uh in the
movie her when he has to show
samantha the world to the lens of his
phone but then at the same time talk to
her through
the phone headphone it just didn't seem
as potentially immersive so to say
um so that's my main goal for augmented
reality like how do we
make your reality a little bit more
magic there's been a lot of really
nice robotics companies that all failed
mostly failed home robotics social
robotics companies what
do you think replica will ever is that a
dream long-term dream to have a physical
form
like um or is that not necessary
so you mentioned like with augmented
reality bringing them into
into the world what about like actual
physical robot that i don't really
believe in that much
i think it's a very niche product
somehow
i mean if a robot could be
indistinguishable from a human being
then maybe yes but that
of course you know we're not anywhere
even to talk about it
um but unless it's that then having any
physical
representation really limits you a lot
because you probably will have to make
it
somewhat abstract because everything's
changing so fast like you know we can
update the 3d avatars every month and
make them look better and
create more animations and make it more
and more immersive it's
it's so much a work in progress it's
just showing what's possible right now
with current tag
but it's not really in any way polished
finished product what we're doing
with a physical object you kind of lock
yourself into something for a long time
anything's pretty niche and again so
just just doesn't the capabilities are
even less of we're
barely kind of like scratching the
surface of what's possible with
just software as soon as we introduce
hardware then
you know we have even less capabilities
yeah in terms of
board members and investors and so on
the cost
increases significantly i mean that's
why you have to justify
you have to be able to sell a thing for
like 500 or something like that or more
and it's very difficult to provide that
much value to people
that's also true yeah and i guess that's
super important most of our users don't
have that much money
we actually are probably more popular on
android
and we have tons of users with really
old android phones
uh and most of our most active users
live in small towns
they're not necessarily making much and
they just won't be
able to afford any of that ours is like
the opposite of the early adopter of you
know for a fancy
technology product which is really
interesting that like
pretty much no vcs have yet have a nai
friend
but you know but a guy who you know
lives in tennessee in
small town is already fully in 2030 or
in the world as we imagine
in the movie her yeah he's living that
life already
what do you think i have to ask you
about the movie her
let's do a movie review what do you uh
what do you think they got
they did a good job what do you think
they did a bad job of portraying about
this experience of um
of a voice based assistant that you can
have a relationship with
first of all i started working on this
company before that movie came out
so it was a very but once it came out it
was like actually
interesting i was like well we're
definitely working on the right thing
we should continue there are movies
about it and then you know smacking that
came out and all these things
in the movie her i think that's the most
important thing that people usually
miss about the movie um is the ending
because i think people check out when
the
ai's leave but actually something really
important happens
afterwards um because the main character
goes and talks to
samantha he's um ai
um oh yeah
anything he says something like you know
uh how can you leave me i've never loved
anyone
the way i loved you and she goes uh well
me neither but now we know how
and then the guy goes and writes a
heartfelt letter to his
ex-wife which he could write for you
know the whole movie he was struggling
to actually write something meaningful
to her
even although that's his job
and then he goes and talked to his
neighbor and they go to the rooftop and
they cuddle and it seems like
something's starting there
and so i think this now we know how is
the
is the main main goal is the main
meaning of that movie
it's not about falling in love with the
os or running away from other people
it's about
learning what you know what it means to
feel so deeply connected with something
what about the thing where the ai system
was like
actually hanging out with a lot of
others
i felt jealous just like hearing that i
was like oh i mean
uh yeah so she was having
i forgot already but she was having like
deep meaningful discussion with some
like philosopher guy
like alan watts or something like what
kind of deep meaningful
conversation can you have with alan
watts in the first place yeah i know but
like i would
i would feel so jealous that there's
somebody who's like
way more intelligent than me and she's
spending all her time with
i'd be like well why that i won't be
able to live up to that
that's thousands of them uh
is that is that a useful from the
engineering perspective
feature to have of jealousy i don't know
as
you know we definitely played around
with the replica universe where
different replicas can talk to each
other the universe is so awesome it was
just
kind of it wouldn't i think it will be
something along these lines but there
was just no
specific uh application straight away
i think in the future again if i'm
always thinking about it
if we had no tech limitations uh right
now
if we could build any conversations any
um
possible features in this product then
yeah i think different replicas talking
to each other would be also quite cool
because that would help us
connect better you know because maybe
mine could talk to yours and then give
me some suggestions and
what i should say or not say i'm just
kidding but like more
can it improve our connections and
because eventually
i'm not quite yet sure that we
will succeed that our thinking is
correct um
because there might be reality where
having a perfect
ai friend still makes us more
disconnected from each other and there's
no way around it
and does not improve any metrics for us
real metrics meaningful metrics so
success
is you know we're happier and more
connected
yeah i don't know
sure it's possible there's a reality
that's i i'm deeply optimistic
i think are you worried um
business-wise like how difficult it is
to um to bring this thing to life to
where it's
i mean there's a huge number of people
that use it already but to uh yeah like
i said in a multi-billion dollar
company is that a source of stress for
you
are you uh super optimistic and
confident
or do you i don't i'm not that much of a
numbers person as you probably
have seen it so it doesn't matter for me
whether like whether we help 10 000
people or
a million people or a billion people
with that um
i'd it would be great to scale up for
more people but
i'd say that even helping one i think
with this
is such a magical yeah for me it's
absolute magic i never thought that
and you know would be able to build this
that anyone would ever
um talk to it and i always thought like
well for me we'll be successful if we
manage to help and
actually change a life for one person
like then we did something interesting
and you know how many people can
say they did it and specifically with
this very futuristic very romantic
technology so that's how i view it
uh i think for me it's important to to
try to figure out how not
how to actually be you know helpful
because
in the end of the day if you can build a
perfect ai friend that's
so understanding that knows you better
than any human out there
can have great conversations with you um
always knows how to make you feel better
why would you choose another human
you know so that's the question how do
you still keep building it so it's
optimizing for the right thing
so it's still circling you back to other
humans in a way
so i think that's the main um like maybe
that's the main kind of sort
source of anxiety and just thinking
about
i think about that can be a little bit
stressful yeah it's a fascinating thing
how to have a heart of a friend
that doesn't like sometimes like friends
quote unquote
or like you know those people who have
when they a guy in the guy
universe when you have a girlfriend that
uh
you get the girlfriend and then the guy
stops hanging out with all of his
friends
it's like obviously the relationship
with the girlfriend is
or whatever but like you also want it to
be what she like
makes it more enriching to hang out with
the guy friends or whatever was
there anyway that that's uh
that's a that's a that's a fundamental
problem in choosing the right mate
and probably the the fundamental problem
in creating the right ai
system right what uh let me ask
the sexy hot thing on the presses right
now is gpt
3 got released with openai it's a latest
language model
they have kind of an api where you can
create a lot of fun applications
i think it's as people have
said it's probably more hype
than intelligent but there's a lot of
really
cool things ideas there
with increasing size you can have better
and better performance on
language what are your thoughts about
the gbt3
in connection to your work with the open
domain dialogue
but in general like this learning
in an unsupervised way from the internet
to generate one character at a time
creating
pretty cool text
uh so we partner up before for the api
launch so we started working with them
when
um they decided to put together this
api and we tried it without fine tuning
that we tried it with fine tuning on our
data
and we worked closely to actually
optimize
this model for
some of our data sets
it's kind of cool because i think we're
kind of we're this polygon polygon for
this kind of experimentation space for
experimental space for for these models
uh to see how they actually work
with people because there are no
products publicly available that do that
that focus on open domain conversations
so we can
you know test how facebook blends are
doing or how gpg3 doing
uh so with gpd3 we managed to improve by
a few percentage points like three
or four pretty meaningful amount of
percentage points our main metric which
is the
ratio of conversations that make people
feel better
and every other metric across across the
field got a little boost
right now i'd say one out of five
responses from replica comes from gpg3
wow so our own blender mixes up like a
bunch of candies from different
blender you said well yeah just the
model that looks at
looks at top candidates from different
models and picks the
most the best one uh so right now one of
five will come from
gp3 that's really great i mean uh
what's the do you have hope for like
do you think there's a ceiling to this
kind of approach so we've had for a
very long time we've used um
since the very beginning we most it was
most of replica was scripted and then a
little bit of this fallback
part of replica was using a retrieval
model um
and then this retrieval model started
getting better and better and better
with transformers it got a lot better
and we're seeing great results and then
with gpd2
finally generative models that
originally were
not very good and were a very very
fallback
option for most of our conversations we
wouldn't even put them in production
finally we could use some generative
models as well along
um you know next to our retrieval models
and then now we do gpt3 they're almost
on par
um so that's pretty exciting i think
just seeing how
from the very beginning of um you know
from 2015 where the first model start
to pop up here and there like sequence
sequence
uh the first papers on that from my
observer standpoint
first note it's not you know it doesn't
really it's not really building it but
it's only testing it on
people basically in my product to see
how all of a sudden we can use
generative
dialogue models in production and
they're better than others
and they're better than scripted content
so we can't really get
our scripted hard-coded content anymore
to be as good as our internet model
that's exciting they're much better
yeah to your question whether that's the
right
way to go i'm again i'm in the observer
seat i'm just
um watching this very exciting movie
um i mean so far it's been stupid to bet
against deep learning so whether
increasing the size size even more or
the 100
trillion parameters will finally get us
to the
right answer whether that's the way or
whether there should be
there has to be some other again i'm
definitely not an expert anyway i think
and that's purely my instincts saying
that there should be something else
as well from memory uh no for sure
the question is i wonder i mean yeah
then the argument is for reasoning or
for memory
it might emerge with more parameters it
might more larger
but might emerge you know i would never
think that to be honest like
maybe in 2017 where we've been just
experimenting with all
you know with all the research that has
been coming that was coming out then
i felt like there's like we're hitting a
wall that there should be something
completely different
but then transformer models and then
just bigger models and then all of a
sudden size matters
at that point it felt like something
dramatic needs to happen
but it didn't and just the size you know
gave us these results that to me are you
know
clear indication that we can solve this
problem pretty soon did uh fine tuning
help
quite a bit oh yeah without it we it
wasn't as good
i mean there is a compelling hope that
you don't have to do fine-tuning
which is one of the cool things about
gbt3 it seems to do well without any
fine-tuning
i guess for specific applications you
still want to train on a certain
like add a little fine-tune on like a
specific use case but
um it's an incredibly impressive uh
thing from my standpoint and again i'm
not
an expert so i want to just say that
yeah there will be people then
yeah i have access to the api i've been
i'm going to probably do a bunch of fun
things with it
um i already did some fun things some
videos coming out
uh just the hell of it i mean i could be
a troll at this point with
it i haven't used it for serious
applications so it's really cool to see
you're right you you are you're able to
actually use it with real people and see
how well it works
that's really exciting uh let me ask you
another absurd question but uh
there's a feeling when you interact with
replica with an ai system there's an
entity there
do you think that entity has to
be self-aware do you think it has to
have consciousness
to create um a rich experience
and a corollary what's what is
consciousness
i don't know if it does need to have any
of those things but again
because right now you know it doesn't
have anything they can as again a bunch
of you sure will
assimilate well
i'm not sure let's just put it this way
but i think as long as you can
assimilate it
if you can feel like you're talking to
to an um
to to a robot to a machine that seems to
be self-aware
that seems to reason well and feels like
a person
and i think that's enough and again
what's the goal
um in order to make people people feel
better we might not even need that
um in the end of a day what about so
that's one goal
what about like ethical things about
suffering you know the moment there's a
display of consciousness
we associate consciousness with
suffering
um you know there's a temptation to say
well shouldn't this thing have rights
shouldn't this
shouldn't we not
uh you know should we be careful about
how we
interact with a replica like
should it be illegal to torture a
replica
right all those kinds of things is that
is that uh
see i personally believe that that's
gonna be a thing uh
like that's a serious thing to think
about but i'm not sure when
but by your smile i can tell that's not
a
that's not a current concern but do you
think about that kind of stuff
about like suffering and torture
and ethical questions about ai systems
from their perspective we're talking
about long game i wouldn't torture your
ai
who knows what happens in five to ten
years yeah they'll get you off from that
person they'll get you back
trying to be as nice as possible and
create this ally
yeah um i think there should be
regulation both way
in a way like i don't think it's okay to
torture an ai to be honest i'm not i
don't think it's okay to yell alex or
turn on the lights i think there should
be some
or just saying kind of nasty you know
like how kids learn to
interact with alexa in this kind of mean
way
uh because they just yell at it all the
time i think that's great i think there
should be some feedback loops so that
these systems don't train us that it's
okay to do that in general
uh so that if you try to do that you
really
get some feedback from the system that
it's not okay with that
um and that's the most important right
now
let me ask a question i think people are
curious about
when they look at a world-class
uh leader and thinker such as yourself
as uh
what uh what books technical fiction
philosophical had a big impact on your
life
and maybe from another perspective what
books would you recommend
others read so my choice the three books
right three books
my choice is um
so the one book that really influenced
me a lot when i was
building starting out this company maybe
10 years ago
uh was gb go to leicester block
and um i like everything about it first
of all
it's just beautifully written and it's
so old school and so
um somewhat outdated a little bit but i
think the ideas in it
um about the fact that a few meaningless
components can
come together and create meaning that we
can't even understand
this emerging thing i mean complexity
the whole science of complexity
and uh that beauty intelligence all
interesting things about this world
emerge yeah
and yeah the the girl theorem
uh theorems and just thinking about like
what even these
form you know you know these formal
systems
something can be created that we can't
quite yet understand
and that from my romantic standpoint
was always just that is why it's
important to maybe i should try to work
on
on these systems and try to build an ai
yes i'm not an engineer
yes i don't really know how it works but
i think that's something comes out of it
that's
you know pure poetry and i know a little
bit about that
um something magical comes out of it
that we can't quite put a finger on
that's why that book is
was was really fundamental for me just
for
i don't even know why it was just all
about this little magic that
uh that happens so that's one that
um probably the most important book for
replica was carl rogers on becoming a
person
um and that's really
and so i think when i think about our
company it's all about there's so many
there's so many little magical things
that happened over the course of
working on it
for instance i mean the most famous chat
bot that we learned about when we
started working on the company was
eliza which was weizenbaum you know the
mit professor that built
build a chatbot that would listen to you
and be a therapist therapist yeah
um and i got really inspired to build
replica when i read
carl rogers so i'll become a person and
then i realized that eliza was mocking
carl rogers it was kyle rogers back in
the day
but i thought that carl rogers ideas are
they're simple and they're not you know
they're very
very simple but they're they're maybe
the most profound thing i've ever
learned about human beings and that's
the fact that um
before car rogers most therapy was about
seeing what's wrong with people
and trying to fix it or show them what's
wrong with you um
it was all built on the fact that most
people are all people are fundamentally
flawed
we have this uh you know broken psyche
and
this is just a therapist just an
instrument to shed some light on that
and carl rogers was different in a way
that he finally said that well
um it's very important for therapy to
work
is to create this therapeutic
relationship where you believe
fundamentally
and inclination to positive growth that
everyone deep inside wants to grow
positively and change
and it's super important to create this
space and this therapeutic relationship
where you give unconditional positive
regard
deep understanding allowing someone else
to be a separate person
full acceptance and you also try to be
as genuine as possible in it
as possible in it and then in his and
then for him that was his own journey of
personal growth and that was back in the
60s
and even that book that is you know it's
coming from
years ago um there's a mention that even
machines can potentially do that
and i always felt that you know creating
this space is probably the most
the biggest gift we can give to each
other and that's why the book was
fundamental for me
personally because i felt i want to be
learning how to do that
in my life and maybe i can scale it with
you know with dzi systems
and other people can get access to that
so i think carl rogers
it's a pretty dry and a little bit
boring book but i think they
didn't let others try to read it i do
i think for just for yourself for
as a human not as a human it's it's it
is
it is just and for him that was his own
path of his own personal of growing
personally over years
working with people like that and so it
was work
and himself growing helping other people
grow and growing through that
and that's fundamentally what i believe
in with our work
helping other people grow growing
ourselves ourselves
um trying to build a company that's all
built on this principles
you know having a good time allowing
some people to work with to grow a
little bit
so these two books and then i would
throw in um
what we have on our in our in our office
when we start a company in russia we put
a
neon sign in our office because we
thought that's that's the recipe for
success
yeah if we do that we're definitely
going to wake up as a
multi-billion dollar company it was um
the ludwig whitney constant quote the
limits of my language the limits of my
world
what was the quote the limits of my
language are the limits of my world
um and i love the truck tattoos i think
it's just
it's just a beautiful it's a book by
wickedthat yeah and i would recommend
that too
even although he himself didn't believe
in that by the end of his lifetime and
he debunked his ideas but i think i
remember
once an engineer came in 2012 i think
with 13
a friend of ours who worked with us and
then went went on to work at deepmind
and he gave
talk to us about ward 2 back and i saw
that i'm like
wow that's you know they they wanted to
translate language into
you know some other representation and
that seems like some
you know somehow all of that at some
point i think will come
into this one to this one place
somehow it just all feels like different
people think about similar ideas in
different times from absolutely
different perspectives
and that's why i like these books in the
midst of our lives
just the limit of our world and
we still have that new sign
it's very hard to work with this red
light in your face
i mean on the on the russian side of
things
in terms of uh language the limits of
language being the limit of our world
you know russian is a beautiful language
in some sense there's width there's
humor there's pain
there's so much we don't have time to
talk about it much today but i'm going
to paris
talk to dusty ascii tulsa translators um
i think it's that's fascinating art like
in
in art and engineering i mean it's such
an interesting process
but so from the replica perspective
do you what do you think about uh
translation
how difficult it is to create a deep
meaningful connection in russian
versus english how you can translate the
two languages
you're you speak both yeah i think we're
two different people in different
languages
um even i'm you know thinking about and
there's actually some research on that i
looked into that at some point
because i was fascinated by the fact
that what i'm talking about with what i
was talking about with my russian
therapist has nothing to do with
with what i'm talking about with my
english speaking therapist
it's two different lives two different
types of
um you know conversations to different
personas
the main difference between the
languages are
with russian and english is that russian
well english is like a piano
it's a limited number of a lot of
different keys but not too many
and russian is like an organ or
something it's just something
gigantic with so many different keys and
so many different opportunities to screw
up
and so many opportunities to do
something completely tone-deaf
it is just a much harder language to use
it has way too many it's like way too
much flexibility
and way too many tones what about the
the entirety of like world war ii
communism
stalin the pain of the people like
having been deceived
by the dream like all the pain of like
just the entirety of it is that in the
language too
does that have to do oh for sure i mean
we have words that don't have
direct translation that to english that
are very much
uh um like we have ibiza which is sort
of like to
hold a grudge or something but it
doesn't have
it doesn't you don't need to have anyone
to do it to you
it's just your state yeah you just feel
like that you feel
like betrayed by other people basically
but it's not that and you can't really
translate that
um and i think this is super important
that very many words that are very
specific
explain the russian being and i think it
can only come from
from a nation that was um that suffered
so much and saw institutions fall
time after time after time and you know
what's exciting
maybe not exciting setting the wrong
word but
what's interesting about like my
generation my mom's generation my
parents generation
that we saw institutions fall two or
three times in our lifetime
and most americans have never seen them
fall yeah and they just think that they
exist forever
um which is really interesting but it's
definitely
a country that suffered so much and and
it makes unfortunately when i
go back and i you know hang out with my
russian friends
uh it makes people very cynical they
stop believing in
in the future i hope that's not going to
be
the case for so long or something's
going to change again
but i think seeing institutions fall is
a very traumatic experience
which makes it very interesting and
what's on 2020
is a very interesting uh
do you think uh civilization will
collapse
see i'm a very practical person we're
speaking in english so like you said
you're different person in english and
russian so
in russian you might answer that
differently but in english
i'm an optimist and i i generally
believe that
there is al you know even although the
perspectives of grief
there's always a place for for a miracle
i mean it's always been like that with
my life so yeah
my life's been i've been incredibly
lucky and things just
miracles happen all the time with this
company with
people i know with everything around me
and so
i didn't mention that book but maybe in
search of miraculous
or in search for miraculous or whatever
the english translation for that is good
russian book too
for everyone to read um
yeah i mean if you put good vibes if you
put
love out there in the world
miracles somehow happen yeah i believe
that too or at least i believe that i
don't know
uh let me ask the most absurd final
ridiculous question
of um we talked about life a lot what do
you think
is the meaning of it all what's the
meaning of life
i mean my answer is probably going to be
pretty cheesy um
but i think the state of love is once
you feel it
in a way that we discussed before i'm
not
talking about falling love or um just
love
to yourself to uh to other people to
something to
the world that state of bliss that we
experience sometimes whether through
connection
with ourselves with our people with the
technology
um there's something special about those
those moments so um
i would say if anything that's that's
the only if it's not for that then for
for what else are we really trying to do
that
i don't think there's a better way to
end it than talking about love
eugenia i told you um offline that
there was something about me that felt
like this
this was this talking to you meeting you
in person will be a turning point
for my life i know that might be sound
weird just
to hear but it's it was a huge honor to
talk to you
i hope we talk again thank you so much
for your time thank you so much
thanks for listening to this
conversation with eugenia cuida and
thank you to our sponsors
doordash dollar shave club and cash app
click the sponsor links in the
description to get a discount and
to support this podcast if you enjoy
this thing
subscribe on youtube review 5 stars on
apple podcast
follow on spotify support on patreon or
connect with me on twitter at lex
friedman and now let me leave you with
some words from carl sagan
the world is so exquisite with so much
love and moral depth
that there's no reason to deceive
ourselves with pretty stories of which
there's little good evidence
far better it seems to me and our
vulnerability
is to look death in the eye and to be
grateful every day
for the brief but magnificent
opportunity that life provides
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time